everybody
and welcome to mid suffolk district
council development control b
my name's kathy guthrie and i'm the
chairman today
excuse me may i first of all remind you
of some domestic arrangements
please ensure that microphones are muted
when you are not speaking
that you do not interrupt the other
speaker members are reminded not to use
the messaging
chat function during the meeting unless
it is to report a pecuniary
non-pecuniary interest or to notify the
chair that you wish to make a proposal
members are reminded they should not
have alternative communication lines
open
i.e other skype chats and that if you
are contacted by a third party during an
application you should bring this to the
legal advisors
attention that if you are attending the
meeting to speak and persistently
interrupt the meeting
you may be asked to leave additionally
you will be invited to speak and ask
questions by myself
please await your turn we will not be
using the hands up function
except for declarations of interest site
visits request
declarations of lobbying and questions
for clarity
if you are experiencing poor connection
issues in the first instance
please turn off your camera this does
not work
please turn off all incoming video these
options are under the three dots in the
main information bar
i would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet
and will be capable of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be
recorded
except whether a confidential or exempt
items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council
to have consented to being recorded by
entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to be recorded
by the council
and for possible use of those sound
recordings for webcasting
and all training purposes
the council members of the public and
press may record film
photograph or broadcast this meeting
when the public and press are not
lawfully excluded
before i go to the introductions for
members
we will do for the debate area the first
round will be a to z
and then as we move forward we can
possibly use the hands up if i can keep
up with you
so introductions ian duprey is our legal
advisor
robert carmichael is our governance
officer
alex scott is case officer area planning
manager john paytman g
we also have um gemma
um who will be um presenting one of the
cases
we also have philip isbell who's also
here to assist
and we also have ward as a ward member
as well as a committee member
councillor stringer so can we move to
the agenda please
i will now ask the governance officer to
roll call for the members present
i'll just turn my video on as well um
apologies there was a slight error there
that in
what i'd written in your order of scenes
council string here is
just here as a normal member not as a
ward member this morning so the war
members we've got are
councillors uh councillor geek and
councillor
mansell and councillor field to
apologies i do apologize
i do apologize to them because i am
reading from a crib sheet and i should
have known that because i welcomed them
earlier
i apologize thank you so if members
could please respond
um with present so accounts for james
carsten
president councillor peter gould
president
councillor kathy guthrie present
counselor barry humphries
president council andrew mellon
president
councillor mike norris president
councillor andrew stringer
president and council roland warboys
president
thank you chair we are all present
to receive declarations of pecuniary and
non-pecuniary interests by members
are there any to declare please use the
hands up function
then learn to declare declarations of
lobbying
are there any to declare and please use
the hands up function
again none declarations of personal site
visits
and anything to declare again please use
the hands up function
thank you the schedule of applications
will be as the order that they are
in in the papers um
so we will be uh dealing with dc 20 016
double seven land to the west
former bacon factory arms well first
followed by
dc2001175 land
adjacent port one business park
and then finally dc 2003026 the crest
nicholson site
land adjacent to weatherdon road um
and just to remind uh those people who
are visiting
the meeting today if they want to
continue to listen that will be fine
but the second one will probably be um
after an hour
but if you do want to just leave for the
moment please
please leave the applications running so
that you can join us later but you're
very
welcome to stay so without further ado
can we move on i'm very sorry chair um
we've missed out the minutes
oh i don't beg your pardon yes but i
don't know why i've done that i'm not
really concentrating am i
sorry i apologize the minutes of the
meeting um
sorry are there any points regarding to
the accuracy of the minutes
counselor mallon please
uh yes thank you chair um i just want to
say that i
i believe i declared uh i'd made a site
visit to mendelssohn and that didn't get
recorded in the minutes
of that counselor yep i can put that in
so can i have a proposal in the second
of the minutes without
amendment please happy to propose
chair councillor mellon thank you for
that
and councillor casten are you seconding
that happy to the second
thank you chair thank you very much for
that um
so robert if you can now take a roll
call please
thank you chair so if members could
please respond with for against or
abstain
so it counts to james carson for
cancer peter gould four
councillor kathy guthrie paul councillor
barry humphries
four councilman andrew mellon
[Music]
thank you and as soon as it's
practicable they will be signed
can you now reduce your hands if you've
got hands up at the moment please thank
you
to receive notification of petitions in
accordance with the council petition
scheme
none received chair thank you and we've
done the schedule of applications so i
do apologize
for that so now i'll ask
daniel cameron to introduce the first
application please thank you very much
chairman can i um just say a couple of
words before dan presents
the application you can indeed please do
thank you chairman um yeah just by way
of introductory comment here i think
it's important that i
uh just just put a couple of things
before members consideration this
morning
um before debate proceeds and the first
point is your officers
have obtained council's opinion on this
application um
the officers report on the planning
merits and the risk issues that are
involved here now
that advice is legally privileged and
isn't being shared with committee as it
contains advice both
on the application in hand and on the
conduct of the appeal presently with
this planning inspector
so with that in mind the risk report
does refer to legal advice
buddies you'll understand framed quite
carefully and only with relevance to the
application before
uh committee today so it's important
secondly to
bear in mind that this application needs
to be determined on its own planning
merits
but it is foreseeable that the
consideration of this application by
this committee may form part of the
evidence and case
which gets argued and presented at that
appeal
the third point uh is your officers will
wish to ensure that at no point during
the conduct of today's meeting is the
defense of that appeal undermined or
compromised by
the rehearsal of issues on that appeal
proposal
inevitably i'd ask you to bear in mind
that may mean that the advice given by
your officers is
framed carefully to safeguard that
defense as need be and members are asked
just to bear that in mind when asking
questions and questions of officers
and in debate and i think that's all i
want to say at this point uh chairman
but obviously happy happy to answer
questions uh
as need be and i'll hand over to dan
thank you for that philip dan um if
you'd like to present the case
thank you cherry you're able to see the
powerpoint presentation
yes i can i hope others can too thank
you yes
excellent okay so um
this is application dc 20
0 167 it's an outline application for
the erection of 65 residential dwellings
as part of the outline we're considering
access but all the other reserve
matters the appearance the layout the
landscaping and the scale of the site
are to be determined under a different
application where this outline to be
approved
so the application was previously heard
on
the 5th of august and that meeting was
deferred
to allow officers time to provide a risk
assessment
such that members could be aware of the
risks of a refusal on this application
and that information is presented in
your report members pages
2017-22
um we do have a live appeal running on
the site from the previous application
that's dc1903924
the reason for refusal is provided
within the report for your members
effectively it is that the site is
unallocated and will place additional
burden on the infrastructure of
venezuela to cope
with particular regard to education
provision
council opinion for the appellants and
for the council
has been undertaken and information
within that is given
for you in the risk assessment pages 17
to 22 members
with regards to the site it's outlined
on the screen for you here in
orange members will note a grade two
listed building some distance
to the west
here's that same map outlined again
outlined again in orange we see elmswell
to the east we have the image of the
former bacon factory site now
uh taylor wimpey housing development and
then we have the farm complex to the
west which contains
listed building
if we jump ahead slightly
to the plans we have before as members
they should all be familiar to us
from the previous meeting there would be
two access points created through to the
taylor wimpy site
um for the creation of up to 65
residential units
here the report as presented on
pages 23 to 47 of your agenda members
is as presented at the meeting on the
5th of august
and the recommendation within that
report members remains the same
such that it is resolved that
such that the recommendation to members
is that they resolve to
grant approval to the application
subject to condition
and subject to um section 106
as well and i think it might be useful
just quickly to run
through the section 106 requirements but
the conditions as well for members are
outlined on page 46 and 47 of your
agendas
so with regards to the section 106 it's
required to
secure the delivery of 22 units of
affordable housing with mix to be agreed
obviously if we still have details on
precise numbers to come forward as part
of the reserve matters
we want to be in a position where we can
agree that 10-year mix
on up-to-date information
they'll also be securing education
contributions
highways contributions including monies
towards a footway cycle link between
wool pitt now as well
a need to undertake travel plan um
there'll also be some bus stop
improvements near the site
and there'll also be a need to manage
and maintain open space within the site
and as part of that i think you'll be
prudent to look at
what occurs with the land reserve for
the link road shown here in this
plan in orange between the attenuation
basin to the north of the site
and the residential development to the
south if we look at what occurred within
the taylor wimpy site adjacent
um that was for the transfer of the land
set aside for the link road
to the council and i would think that
something similar
would occur here obviously what we'd be
looking at within the reserve matters
is some sort of intermediary measure to
lay out that site
transfer it
such that when the neighborhood plan
comes forward and we have further detail
on the link road
that land is safeguarded in the
council's ownership and can then be
drawn down upon to provide said link
road
i won't go through the rest of the sites
for members as i said before it should
all be
familiar and if any questions arise we
can run through
the issues and the relevant slides when
we get to them this line just shows you
the two proposed access points in
further detail members
um if there is
nothing there's nothing else for me to
report to members at this point what
i'll do is i'll turn over
to members and take any questions on the
risk assessment itself thank you for
that daniel
um i think on the recommendations we we
do
um you've laid it out very clearly for
us
um but i think the contribution needs
for the uh footwear and cycleway needs
to be
sort of in black and white that that's
five five two fifty as in when we come
to debate that further
to be noted yes so
does anyone have any questions for
clarity please
um you may use the hands up but bear
with me if i slow down
right councillor stringer first then
sarah counts uh well counselor mansell
can you wait while we just go through
the committee members please
so councillor stringer thank you chair
uh on page 19
uh and the penultimate paragraph uh it
says about the development plan policy
cs1 cs2 and h7
are deemed out of date what the report
doesn't go on to say is then what you do
with those policies
do you do you then basically ignore them
or do you identify their conflict
and then balance it out after that
chairman may i chip in on that yes
please do um
so they are development plan policies so
you are required by statute to
give them weight uh what you will find
inspectors and planning authorities
doing this situation is to reduce that
weight
in their consideration they are still
part of the development plan statutorily
they are
supposed to be the the policies that are
your starting consideration
but relative to other considerations
their weight is reduced
by the degree to which they are uh
inconsistent with the national policy
that's the advice that's given
uh given in within the nppf and is
traditionally understood
so in this situation that the policies
being
out of date uh would mean that you would
give greater weight
to the presumption in favor of
sustainable development
and you would give lesser weight to the
development plan policies acknowledging
that they are
for the sake of the record development
plan policies chairman
thank you very much for that explanation
councillor stringer um
has that helped you in your
understanding rather than debating does
it help you in your understanding
uh yes it does so i'll it'd be handy if
i
i'll ask later where it is in the report
but anyway
that's helpful thank you thank you
councillor stringer
and um just before i go to councillor
mansell are there any other questions
from the committee members no then thank
you councillor mansell
uh your question please for clarity
thank you uh
thank you chair um i i it was just
something i picked up
from what uh mr cameron said about
contributions to improving nearby bus
stops
uh just to point out i'd like to know
where the nearby bus stops are because
there are no public bus stop
stops in elmswell north of the railway
line uh and
so i just wondered where nearby bus
stops were intended to be
they would be sorry they would be to the
south of railway line that's come
forward as part of our
um consultation with the highway
authority um
and it's set out within the responses
within the report there
see if i can find you the direct page
so yeah so we're looking at pages 28 to
29
um
[Music]
yeah so it would be as part of bus stop
improvements within elms well but it
wouldn't be
north of the railway line it would be
south of the railway line okay
that's just uh it's a bit misleading to
say that they're near by the site that
was all
thank you councillor mansell that's
uh given you the answer there so we
don't have um any public speakers
uh a representative from the parish
council or objector
so um we can now go straight to the ward
members we have two and
councillor sarah mansell i have you as
the first one
up so if you'd like to make your
representation thank you very much
uh thank you my views on this
application
remain unchanged despite the words the
risk assessment
and the legal advice which i have been
informed about
from our planning officers whatever they
and the county council say it is still
fundamentally wrong
to be educating the children of elmswell
in a new school
built in woolpit here we are in the 21st
century
when we've all admit that there is a
climate emergency
covid has given the environment a bit of
a breather and we as a council have
pledged to promote
sustainable travel that means walking
and cycling
as opposed to using the private car if a
primary school
is nearly three miles away most parents
will not
be walking or cycling with their
children they will be driving
there has been no change to the
nonsensical suggested alternative route
to avoid the congested junction near the
church in elmswell
and before you all start on about
electric vehicles i will admit
that they are an improvement but they
are not the panacea
the energy still has to come from
somewhere and maybe that could be from
renewable sources
but the materials used in battery
technology are far from safe
over 60 percent of particulate pollution
from vehicles comes from brake and tire
dust and from road surface wear
the use of electric vehicles will make
little difference to this and they will
still create traffic jams
this may not be an argument for a
development control committee but the
distribution of housing
in this part of our district is
fundamentally flawed
if you choose to live in one of the
largest villages in the county the
largest village in our district
you would expect there to be a primary
school within that village to
accommodate the children of that village
this is where we need to be heading to
enable as many children as possible
to uh live within walking distance of
their primary school
we know that parents do have a choice
but we really hope that in the future it
will become the norm for the vast
majority of people to walk to school
not be driven three miles across a busy
junction
we need to be doing so much more to
promote this modal shift towards cycling
and walking
so maybe we need to consider the
introduction of cycle share scheme as
part of
sustainable travel plans of this and any
other development in elmsworld
yes i'll admit that some of the funds
will go towards a shared cycle and
pedestrian path between the two villages
but without any additional way of
promoting cycling
this does not cut the biscuit for me
this development
does still sit outside of both the
existing and the proposed settlement
boundary for elmsworld
so we really should only be allowing an
exemplary development in terms of its
environmental sustainability
and this is not it this development is
one too many for elmswell and should be
refused
thank you for that councillor um so can
we go for hands up if any um
are you happy to take questions now
before i ask counselor geek
it doesn't matter whatever is easier for
members whether it's easier to do us on
block
or we'll do we'll do this one now then
shall we
um cancel anybody got any questions
for councillor mansell please before we
ask councillor geek
no thank you very much for that
councillor geek if you would like to
give us your presentation please thank
you very much
thank you chair uh i would like to
support councillor mansell's statements
and add a few points
um we have heard that the site is
outside the settlement boundary in the
emerging joint local plan and it's not a
preferred
option in the plan it will further
expand elmsl to the west resulting in a
major addition to an already
significantly expanded settlement
and it imposes further strain on the
infrastructure provision which is
already stretched to accommodate the 634
houses in elmsworld with planning
commission
both those currently built or soon to
start
these extra 65 houses they're an
unacceptable addition to an already over
extended village particularly at a time
when the council can demonstrate a
five-year housing land supply
now the fact that this site isn't
included in the joint local plan land
allocations or in the neighborhood plan
that was a factor that was cited by
several members in the debate in the
decision in february
there's no difference now to the waiting
that should be given to the joint local
plan compared to
february but ironically as
in a sensible situation where the
village could choose which sites to
accept to meet its required allocations
it might accept this one in favor of
perhaps rejecting the application to
develop the field with the wonderful
view on the edge of the village near the
church
but apparently we aren't in a sensible
situation
so all i can really say in frustration
is given where we are this
application is one too far and should be
refused
but could we please not get into this
situation again
thank you
thank you councillor geek does anyone
have any questions for councillor geek
please
thank you very much for that i don't
have any questions there so
we now move into debate please and can
we start with councillor casting please
thank you
um thank you chair i have no comments to
make
at this stage thank you and
councillor gould we're now in debate
thank
uh you uh nothing to say at this point
thank you
and councillor humphreys
madam chair thank you um not too much to
say it's just um
we talk about the education yet the
education is part of the rdp
so that's been dealt with it's going to
be in wall pit not known as well i mean
that's that's the decision that's been
made
and there is going to be a cycle route
are we keeping the argument about cars
there are going to be electric cars in
fact september was the record
month for sales of electric cars in the
uk 34 000 so it's going to go up and up
and up
and people will choose to use cars or
they choose to cycle
or they choose to walk it's a choice
thing it's not a reason for stopping
anything
so i can't see anything in the report
that prevents this
it's a natural place to build and i
think it'd be hard to find a refusal
point
thank you for that councillor um
councillor mellon
uh thank you chair um not a great deal
to say beyond what was discussed at our
previous
um time we looked at this the um
the legal opinion um
i don't know it seems to sort of hem us
in even more
in terms of uh you know the actual
the scope we have for decision making
here um
but i i do find this this point
of the educational provision to be
absolutely key
that we have
development in elmswell which could be
accommodated
and then we have to decide on an
application which will take things over
and above that
and the answer to it apparently is to
bust children
to woolpit which just seems to be
um completely incomprehensible to me um
so that's the point where i am at the
moment thank you chair
thank you for that counsellor councillor
norris
thank you uh i do relate to what the
ward members have presented but
i'm struggling to find and particularly
in view
of the risk assessment that's been
presented to us
i am struggling to find defensible
planning reasons to refuse this
application
that's all i'd like to say at this time
thank you
thank you councillor norris council of
all boys
yes i think i i was following from my uh
counselor norris it
the the comments about the education
every village should really be
uh providing its own primary education
and children should be encouraged to use
it
there will be um an existing
pedestrian route and a cycle route
developed as part of this
um and it is at all intense at
greenfield
site but again i mean our
original discussion was was about the
scale of the development and the
increased burden on the infrastructure
in the envelope which persists
um i've fed through the
uh risk assessment and i think you know
we've been well advised there
but i i was a bit concerned about the
sort of
dismission dismissive and divisive tone
of the uh appeals qc
notes and especially that he's
challenging
the payments for additional
improvements to the infrastructure
thank you councillor war boys councillor
stringer
uh thank you chair yeah for me this is
the first time looking at this because i
wasn't
at the previous committee i don't think
uh so uh
yeah it's really interesting there's a
number of points in here that actually
caused me deep concern
and where we have these sort of broad
brushing statements about our policies
that on closer inspection actually are
founded to be
incorrect there there is a paragraph in
here
that states uh that cs1 for instance the
policy cs1
uh that we gain our five-year land
supply
despite it well cs1
if which we all should be very familiar
with is to just that we should have the
majority of our development
in the most sustainable villages and
towns
i wouldn't suggest we've hit the
five-year land supply
despite that i would say it's because of
cs1
because we've concentrated the
development in the most sustainable
places
is why we've hit that target so actually
that statement is fundamentally wrong
so i i think some of the advice is is
very questionable
i think at the core of this issue uh for
this particular
settlement is this thing about the
education provision
now having you know represented the
county council at times
uh you know people can disagree with
them uh
and actually on this case i
fundamentally disagree with them
the fact that an officer of the county
council said well it'll be okay to bust
them to warp
and this is the fundamental first plank
of sustainability
when we have tiny little villagers with
their own primary education provision
in our district our largest one it
should be an absolute benchmark that it
has to provide that primary education so
so
so frankly for me this application does
not wash its face for that
infrastructure for education despite
what my county colleagues are saying
uh and and i believe this one is again
yet another developments the wrong side
of the tracks
chairman can i can i just chip in
because yeah yeah sorry
just before you do phillip can i just
say that um i think councillor warboy's
comment about
the legal advice if ian could just help
me on this i think was
um from the appellant side could you
clarify that ian please
i think i'm yes i'm assuming that
council of war boys is referring to the
opinion from
uh council elite leading council of qc
who was
instructed for the appellant in the
appeal that was the the actual appellant
shared with us because it was
of what he said and i think that mr
isabel i think that
that is in the public domain isn't it or
at least yes
yeah not only remember it's on it's more
or less on our website isn't it i think
because it was
shared with us openly yes so councillor
warboys does that clarify it for you
that in fact
yes that that was what i was referring
to i i did assume it was in the public
domain
yes yes but it was from the appellant
side not from um the legal advice that
mid-suffolk have had just for clarity on
that one yes that's absolutely correct
thank you and the appel i mean although
we've said our advice is legally
privileged
we the officers and our council do not
necessarily agree with every word of the
the advice by mr manley qc that um
the other side showed us thank you thank
you for the clarity on that so long as
we know where it was coming from because
we've had so much
now philip if you'd just like to help on
councillor stringer's point thank you
thank you yes and much as ian has said
there um
they might say that and i suppose in the
christine keel away well they would
wouldn't they
um that doesn't mean we necessarily
agree with their argument
i i i think um the
the the point about the report is that
it's the basket of policies which
are uh not up to date so uh
the approach cs1 cs2 and cs
and h7 together form the approach to uh
housing provision across the district
and together
they are uh not up to date and therefore
together despite those policies
uh the the supply of of homes does not
marry up with the government's policy
and is not consistent with it i don't
think that the statement particularly
drew out cs1
from that and if cs1 looks to focus
growth in particular settlements uh
then and within settlements
or in the area of settlements i think
one can certainly say that
uh there is an argument to be had that
development adjacent to those
settlements
is not uh in in conflict with them
either way
the statement made in the report is
intent to as inspectors do
time and again in appeal address the
policies as a whole because that is how
they should be applied
thank you chairman thank you for that um
and so
um uh in the first round of debate here
i'd like to make a comment
um i hear what everybody is saying about
the schooling
um and i i just sort of
i'm a bit saddened about it because i
know
that each village would love to have
their own school and it's not always
possible
if the county are going to invest in a
new school
at woolpit i can think of nothing better
how exciting
to have a new school that will be
purpose-built
and it will be for those young children
of today and tomorrow
and without harking on about it i can
remember when i had
containers as schooling and that was in
my
six age 16 so we didn't i know that's
not primary schools
but i think to have an exciting new
school is positive
we've got funding towards this
psychopath that
um we're all talking about um
i really think you have to start
somewhere not all children will be
sort of born at once needing to go to a
school there is a school already there
and so i hear what everybody is saying
but i'm still more comfortable with
what's on offer here
so that's my comments for this first
time round we are in debate
so we need to come to some sort of
conclusion
so if anybody would like to use the
hands up function i'll be happy to
try and keep up with you all whoops
there we go there's councillor humphreys
um yes please
man chair thank you um we've heard a few
points there about the education and the
lack of education helms well and we
should have school now as well
we have a school in helm as well it's
going to be expanded so page 39 is quite
useful
and we'll come to council string as well
sustainability i disagree in your
in your um in your opinion on
sustainability problems well completely
and and that's backed up on page 39 as
well it's range it's got railway it's
got good access to roads
it is sustainable all within 12 minutes
of this site
um the school side of it it talks about
provision
of education facilities and it talks
about
uh the growth within elmswear and
wallpaper we accommodated through
expansion of the existing primary school
within elmswell
to 420 people places and through
creation of a new primary school at
walpit
again providing 420 places and as the
chairman
has already said um that's fantastic a
new school
and expansion of an existing school it
can't be too bad can it
you add into it that actually we're
building a footpath
cycleway it's got good road access for
the people that want to use cars and
they will still want to use cars
and we can also use buses and so getting
to the school in woolpit again no issues
whatsoever
i think this is a sustainable location
for development
and that development because it's
sustainable it's supported by the mppf
um suffolk county council have also
identified the expansion of primary
secondary education
can be accommodated in line um with the
approach outlined within within the rdp
so again all good i can find no
reason at all in the papers in front of
me
to refuse this application so i am
minded to
um to approve thank you for that that's
a recommendation from me do i have a
seconder for that proposal please
sorry madam chair for a point point of
clarity uh that is a proposal
yes sorry i thought yes thank you for
clarity
so i have a proposal do i have a second
please
counselor constant thank you madam chair
happy to um second
councillor humphreys proposal thank you
and so now we have a proposal in a
second we can go around again but i'll
do it in the hands up function
and counselor stringer you have your
hand up and counselor melon and just
slow down let me catch up with you
so councillor stringer
thank you chair uh it won't cause anyone
any surprise that
i disagree with the uh the mover and the
secondary this motion
uh to say that this site has good road
access
it's sort of uh i think we'll give house
of derision from
those that live in elmsville and to say
that the the road access supported by
the mppf
is is really not not right also
the the infrastructure for this site and
the joint local plan
etc has been flagged up but this has not
been
yet passed inspection all this
infrastructure delivery and
bringing this this school in wall pit
for the children of elmswall
hasn't actually passed an inspection yet
so i think
you know i i again think the original
decision of the
of this of this uh committee was was the
right one
uh so i won't be voting in favor of this
application
thank you councillor stringer uh
councilman
madam chair sorry could i just intervene
as a point of order um
council stringer misquoted me completely
um
i didn't say the road was supported by
the mppf i said sustainable development
was supported by the mppf thank you uh
thank you for that thank you uh
councillor stringer as
well for your comments and councillor
humphreys councillor mellon please
um yes thank you chair um can i just
have a bit of clarity
on the provision of the cycleway
footpath link
um it's mentioned in paragraph 5.1 on
page 41
um and then we're talking about a
contribution i think 55
000 towards it can we have some clarity
about how far
that 55 000 will go um is
is if we if we approve this application
is it guaranteed that the cycleway
and footpath link will be built is there
enough funding for it or is it dependent
on other um development within elm as
well to provide that
daniel can you help us yeah thank you
chair
um yeah so the 55 000 won't
deliver the entirety of the footwear
cycleway although that is being brought
forward within
um summer county council's five-year
plan for
footwear and cycleway delivery so it's
not
um
i'm trying to think of the right word
apologies it's it's not deliverable on
the back of this development alone it
would be delivered
in concert with a number of other
developments but that's not unusual
for how infrastructure infrastructure to
support delivery of
um infrastructure supported by delivery
of development is brought forward
so we've got a number of um applications
or sites to be brought forward through
the the joint local plan
crownsville world pit all of which would
be required
to contribute so at present we have the
um site names well at school road
um which will bring forward a
significant chunk of that
um we have also the site
in woolpit that will be delivering the
primary school and that will also be
delivering a chunk
of uh said footwear cycleway link as
well
right so the statement that the proposal
has made i think
which was that we will have a cycle link
that that is not really it can't be
conditioned by this approval
i think that's what what you're saying
so the cycleway won't be delivered in
entirety on the back of this development
however we do have a commitment from
suffolk county council
that they want to bring it forward
within the next five years and we have a
number of developments going on in
elsewhere and will pit they're also
expected to make contribution towards it
i think i think it's worth remembering
as well that we are dealing with an
outline planning application so there'd
be a delay between
any grant of this permission approval of
reserve matters which would still need
to come back to committee for additional
scrutiny
um so there'd be a time delay there so
we'd be seeing some of that
infrastructure being brought forward in
any case for on the back of
other developments and this development
would secure funding to see that come
forward as well
i think mr isbell can give us a bit more
help on the uh 106 with regard to that
can you know
mr israel uh thank you chairman yes i
mean i think the point here is we
we have uh as you'd expect we have
confidence in the county council's plans
whether they be for
education or for the delivery of highway
infrastructure
so from our perspective the capturing of
the money here and the fact that this is
already
you know you know in a plan is a is a is
a thing which as a planning authority we
may
have confidence in um it doesn't
guarantee delivery per se
but uh as with most things in in
planning decisions there is there is a
commitment there which i think you know
is in the public domain and one can
take comfort from um there was a related
point i guess which is also the progress
of the amazon neighborhood plan
and its aspiration as as i'd understood
to deliver
the bypass route um just going through
the report i don't believe we'd included
that within the
section 106 obligations chairman and i
would recommend that if
uh if members are content to that we had
an obligation to
safeguard a potential bypass route
consistent with the approach we took in
the taylor wimpy scheme adjacent so
effectively that's an additional
bullet under brackets little one of the
recommendation an additional
additional obligation to safeguard
potential bypass route
thank you jim and can councillor
humphries and councillor casten agree
with that
edition please or disagree yeah i agree
you agree cancer casting yes i think
that's a very good idea
yeah to safeguard it counselor melon
thank you for your question
and debate have you had sufficient
information now
yes i'm just wondering um
we've had other similar applications and
it may have come forward with reserve
matters that we could
could we condition uh
um first occupation of the site
on the on the footpath
and cycleway link already haven't been
constructed i mean this is probably not
a question for now but
no it probably isn't can can the officer
just correct us on that please
so within the section 106 agreement
we'll have a
series of triggers um related to the
provision of the cypher way
so i think probably what we'd be looking
to do is we'd be looking
to um set an appropriate trigger point
within development for
payment of monies and then we'd probably
be looking to
impose a similar um sort of restriction
on the county council to see those
monies used and for delivery of the
of the cycleway being brought forward
now i don't think we'd be
um and i i assume mr dupree can come in
and correct me as well if i'm if i'm
misspeaking here
but i think probably what we wouldn't be
able to do within section 106
is tie the occupation of this site
to delivery of infrastructure offsite um
we are in control of the delivery of the
infrastructure and i say we
of course mean the suffolk county
council at the same time
so provided we can get that money in in
a reasonable time
which i don't think would be um
something that we would necessarily
struggle on
we can then look to chibi along
the county council using our own methods
rather than
um limiting occupation of this site in
that manner
and i also think at the moment um we've
got to be careful
that we are debating of an off-site
issue whereas we've got the monies
towards it so we've got to look at this
site and what it's providing
would i be correcting that um daniel
yes chair i think so thanks lovely so
there we are councillor mellon hopefully
that gives you a little bit more
thinking time thank you and does anyone
else wish to speak that we
now have a proposal and a second are on
the table
in which case then we will go to the
vote if we may please
can i ask you robert to call a vote
thank you
and remember remember i think
just before we do go uh can members
are they happy with the recommendation
with those additions
you don't need to have it read out a
second time so
if we can go to the vote on that basis
um over to you robert
thank you chair so if members could
please respond with for
against or abstain
so councillor james carsten four
master peter gould four
councillor kathy guthrie four
councillor barry humphreys four
councillor andrew mellon against
chancellor mike norris four
councillor andrew stringer against
and counselor roland walk boys against
thank you chair i make that five votes
for three against it with no abstentions
if we confirm mr depray
yes indeed i confirm five votes for
three against no abstentions the
resolution
has been passed thank you very much
indeed
um now we've only been going in now do
members want to have a break
or shall we keep going
keep going right happy to keep going
so we now move on
to our second application and gemma
walker's going to present this case for
us
lander jason port 1 business and
logistics park
so if you'd like to present the case
please thank you chad i'll just uh share
the powerpoint
why is that right
can you see the powerpoint
we can see something i'm not sure yes
but it's a different document
sorry i recognize my own hands
sorry uh
having i'll go for desktop then and that
will allow me to
circumvent that sorry everybody right
let's try that one
apologies sorry i don't know what
happened there
um right yes this is land adjacent to
port one business park
um blackhead hill in great blakenham and
it's an outline planning application
with access to be considered
it's uh in the parish great bacon and
not within the
um assessment boundary but noting that
great bloking itself is a key service
center
this is the red line in the application
site which probably doesn't mean a great
deal for the moment but i will go on to
just show that in a bit more detail
we can just see this is the betrayal 1 3
here
an access coming through here and this
is the energy for waste but i said
hopefully the next plan will show that
in a
more detail so again just the red line
so here we go this is the uh
what's up with the a14 coming down here
uh on the beach
one three and then up and access into
the site with orion business park
the portland business park the green
houses which members may well be
familiar with
the energy from waste building and then
over to the top we've got the
snow asus site on there as well so see
quite a cluster of
commercial and uh employment development
on the locality
so again just to take that out um access
onto the a14
and that corridor through there
so again just to return to that zoomed
in version of the site um
this is just showing public rights of
way that surround the site
[Music]
and then just to reflect the changes
going forward in the draft joint like
plan noting it is draft
and we're not you know proposing to give
it weight particularly in the
considerations application it does
nonetheless give us an idea of the
expectations going forward so you can
just see the pink line hopefully
uh around the edge of the application
site
that is the extension to the assessment
boundary and then the
the blue dashing is um an employment
allocation
and then this is the approved red line
that which had previously been approved
on the application site so again there
is an extant consent for development on
part of this site i will show members
how the site sort of layer together
part of this site essentially doesn't
have consent for any development but a
significant proportion already does have
consent
so again we can see the red line of the
site boundary to the north with orion
business park
the suffolk energy from waste in purple
and the greenhouses
site in green
[Music]
and so here we can see the red line for
the original planning permission
this is the greenhouses to the south
and then we layer on our site so you can
see that it is essentially only a small
portion that doesn't already
essentially have permission and this
will there we go
just show the part of the site that sets
out of
side of any extent planning permission
boundaries you can see it is
essentially primarily um
consented okay just some ideas of
typical warehouse specifications in
terms of ridge heights we'll come back
onto that in a bit i've got some levels
plans just to show members because i
appreciate that that's been
um something that's at question from our
point of view but i'll run through that
in a second so again just picking out
some of the
previously approved we can just see the
energy from waste site up there
[Music]
so um i said it's not currently
allocated it is
countryside but we do think it's
generally consistent with our local plan
policies
and having regard for the presumption in
favor of sustainable development
and noting again that going forward in
the jlp
it is included in terms of clogging and
breaking them with addison way
um you know that it's an area for
expected um
commercial and employment development
looking at adequate highway access being
sensitive to its surroundings and high
quality design so they're you know
things that we would like to look at
going forwards
the overall sort of location site is
down that
uh corridor where we might expect
commercial employment developments
good access onto the a14 and overall
somewhere where
you know despite the fact we are looking
at essentially this being countryside
that employment development would seem a
logical place to feed into that corridor
[Music]
and again it's looking at support for
the council's strategic priorities
um and that open for business strategy
supporting
economic development to move on to that
economic development point we have had
comments from the economic development
team who confirm that they've got no
objection
that it would be a good strategic
employment site offering growth
with they approximate 675 new jobs for
the district
to move on to access arrangements
because access is included in this
outline proposal
you can see in yellow hopefully you can
see my mouse too
the existing access of addison way which
is in only
and then we've got the green arrow which
is the new access that's proposed as
part of this which is
left turns in and right turns out so
essentially you can come up either way
from branford road and turn in
and then you can only turn left into the
site so there's no access
from branford road this way and then
when you exit the site
it's right turn out only so you've got
to come down this way into branford road
and hopefully members will be
very familiar you can only in fact turn
left out of here on broadford road
so you are essentially forced to go out
to the a14
junction now obviously we can't stop to
people turning around at the roundabout
and coming back
but essentially we're pushing traffic
onto the a14
to keep that um you know heavy traffic
potentially
going on to the a14 and onto that main
corridor
so just to pick out on the illustrative
layout as you can see
nice yellow dots hopefully uh quite
visible they're the buildings that the
subject of this application
was the buildings in here have
previously consented
and then just to zoom in on some of the
landscaping proposals which includes a
fair amount of landscaping and surface
water drainage proposals
uh initially surface water drainage um
the county
floods and water had raised an objection
but they're now content that we can deal
with that by condition through part of
the reserve matters
and then just to uh pick up on the
indicative site proposal so the three
buildings in the center
are essentially the they're both
consented and then the four down here
and the larger one to the front
that is what we're looking at as part of
this current proposal
so again just to pick up on the highways
you can see
that we're talking um the left in
right out and how that this junction you
can only turn left here you you can't
come
down onto branford road to the south
so to pick up on the levels this
application did mention having a 50
meter ridge height which i think is um
you know something that you might
initially say oh 50 meters that's quite
significant i think energy from waste is
37 and a half meters
but having said that there are some
significantly tall buildings in the area
and actually some of this comes down to
levels so if i just um
try and run through that quite quickly
so section a at the top here
is looking straight through the four
proposed buildings here so
starting at the left hand side is at the
top and you can see we just work down
through the site
it doesn't give you the sort of
relations to the existing buildings the
other sections are perhaps slightly more
helpful on that one
so again section b we're looking through
the existing buildings and consented
so this is the darker gray building
coming down to the
lesser grey building and the the yellow
is the proposed so you can see although
it would have a significant ridge height
actually it is related to
the existing buildings and then the same
again if we look at c d which are coming
across the site
so we're looking through this building
here on this elevation and then through
the
uh consented proposals it is not
dissimilar
and it makes use of the levels across
the site
and again with a you can see that we
make use of those levels
having said that we are proposing a
condition which essentially says we're
not agreeing a specific
maximum or minimum ridge height here
what we would like to do is to
save that for the reserve matters
because when we get to reserve matters
we will look at
specifically scale and appearance and
that scale
we think should be something that we
agree at that point but having said that
you can see
roughly how it might fit in and that
we're not um
yeah we don't consider that's
unacceptable to consider refusal on that
basis at this stage
but that we can save that as something
we look at at reserve matters
and again you know when we're looking
through the area there are a lot of tall
buildings
in that cluster so starting with
snowasis
which i think comes in i think it's 97
sorry i've lost that bear with me i'll
see if i can double check that one that
one for you but
um there are the energy from waste you
can see here
and then the green houses
so uh in conclusion really yes it is in
the countryside but we are talking
essentially a small extension to
existing it's quite similar to the
existing
and contented proposals and it would
overall be considered to be a reasonable
location and offer good benefits in
terms of
the economy um so the proposal is um
sorry the recommendation is for approval
that is subject to a deed of variation
so that we
uh mirror across the 106 agreements
previously which related primarily to
travel plan
and some some highways works
and then that we grant permission
subject to conditions
i hope that's clear and thank you chair
if there's any questions more than happy
to
help thank you for that gemma there are
a few points that we do need to add
before members
go to questions in that in the
recommendations
um we haven't got anything about bats
ecology
and also archaeology seems to have been
missed off the
recommendations um and then you also
alluded
to traffic management
and i know suffolk is looking at the
whole thing um
i know our councillors will be able to
help us on that uh
for uh lorry movements and so on is
there any way that we could
restrict um them going from the site
okay up round the roundabout and coming
back down again but clearly to join the
a12
is there anything we can do with that if
you could consider that yeah
thank you okay so conditions yes
uh so the archaeology conditions which i
think
are pages of 162
and also the ecology conditions which
are also detailed in full pages 170 to
172 or 73
no they're not in the recommendation
they should be in the recommendations so
the recommendation would also include
the archaeology conditions as detailed
on those pages and the ecology
conditions as detailed on those pages
[Music]
in terms of traffic no i think they have
done the
the maximum they can in terms of
stopping traffic going up
branford road into great blakenham um
okay well we'll we'll debate that as it
goes forward but that was just a point
right um so uh thank you for that
so members if you'd like to have hands
up to ask the officer any questions
please do so so councillor mallon please
and then i've missed whoever the other
one is i look down so
councillor mallon uh thank you chair um
yes just wanted to ask the officer um
one of the early slides showed
a lot of uh vegetation trees
on the site but i couldn't see in
papers where um the details of how many
trees are going to be lost by this
development have you ever any idea and
what's the sort of maturity of those
trees
thank you
um so i think hopefully this this
slide's
slightly helpful from this one the
majority of the site as you can see is
actually
already under development um so i think
we're looking at something like
four 4.8 hectares um
that doesn't currently have consent for
works on and again the majority of the
trees are around the outskirts of the
site
and if i come back down to that one so
that those around the outskirts are
are kept as part of the proposal and
with some replacement but
landscaping would be um part part of the
reserve matters and i think we've also
got a condition on it to control that
but i
i can't specifically answer how many
trees might be lost
but i hope that helps help somewhat um
yes sorry you sort of shuttled back back
and forth between the slides before i
could really get it but
there was a belt of trees uh across the
middle of the site which seems to be
completely gone at the end so
would that be correct that there's a
good chunk that are being lost in
let me see if i can find me
um
yeah i can't see from this whether
they're mature trees or whether you know
something fairly newly planted it looks
like
some sort of um planting that's been
done on an earlier scheme perhaps
uh cathy could i make it come in
well i will let you in in a minute but
can we
yes i think you're right there's a belt
of trees across there
if it if it's relating to this i think
councillor field might be able to help
us
i was going to come to you after captain
stringer but just for this point
i was just going to point out that as
you know this land was owned by michael
blakenham who was a fairly renowned
environmentalist and there were a string
of trees up there that he
lovingly preserved for various reasons
for a great period of time
we just want to know if there were two
trees up there they
there are and they're of a great value a
number of them
i don't know which ones are the ones of
great value
okay i'll come back to you in a minute
because you've got your hand up as well
so
um so councillor mellon that does that
help you
that you've got the answer to your
question at the moment and perhaps
the officer can perhaps look through um
the photographs and see if they can
identify them again
um and then we'll come on to councillor
stringer for his question and can you
put your hands down if you've spoken
please yeah so yeah just a bit more
information on the trees would be
helpful thank you chad
thank you chair uh i'm sorry i've got
five questions um
sorry does this uh does this application
allow
for the storage of containers because
most logistics and lorry warehousing
stuff
allows you as a permitted development to
stack containers up to four high
so can i have some clarity on that
could i also have page 185
there is a yellow hatched area
on the adjacent site can i can be
confirmed that is the triple s i
for archaeological reasons because i can
get from this map there's a spectacular
cliff
believe it or not uh in the middle of
suffolk there is there is
a cliff there which is incredibly
wildlife
it's stacked with wildlife and also you
can see right down to the ice age
that that needs to be very sensitively
treated at that juncture
no i'm not debating i'm just reasoning
i'm asking the question yeah well no we
don't need that we just want the
question
okay can they answer the first two
questions because you've got three
i have so um jenna can you answer the
first two questions for us please
yep so i don't believe there's any
expectation for um
storage containers if i just go back to
the certification plan
and sorry for overriding you there gemma
i mean there is a condition recommended
which is for no outside storage i mean
it doesn't talk about containers
specifically but it's
it's something that we can include and
this is the stage the outline stage is
the time to do it if if
that's of concern to committee thank you
that's helpful
and then the second question for
councillor stringer and then we'll come
back to him for his others the yellow
hatched area
and the triple s i area is that the area
that we've put in the condition for
archaeology and that sort of thing
it would have been what archaeology
looks at the archaeology condition is in
full on page
162 and then on to 163 yeah but it
wasn't in the conditions so we know but
that's what we're proposing we do
include
yep to protect the archaeology as county
have recommended yeah so councillor
stringer far away
your street okay another three so
are we suggesting then that traffic is
can turn
right and then right out of here and go
through sprawling
um also uh my four
fourth question and i'm nearly there
have we got uh condition for vehicle
charging points
on this and also is there a condition
relating to cs3
cs3 means any building over a thousand
square meters that's non-residential
should generate 10 percent of its own
power uh renewably
this is 000 square meters uh could we
could we be shown where that condition
is thank you of course thank you
thank you uh so the writing write out
junction
is um so i said if you're coming off
this junction
you can turn in you can't come this way
and turn in that's that's not available
if you're coming out of the site you've
got to turn right
and at this point you've also got you've
got to turn left sorry
you've got to go up towards the a14
junction
as i said before i can't we can't
prohibit people doing essentially you
turn around that
right you know going all the way around
the roundabout and coming back south but
essentially traffic will not be able to
turn directly south to go
through the villages and you know i
think the expectation from county
highways is having gone to the a14
roundabout the likelihood should be that
you then go on the a14 rather than
through any villagers
does that help that one uh conditional
vehicle charging points
yes i believe there is a conditional
vehicle charging points if i stop
showing my screen in a second i can
check the bullet points
and the same on cs3 there's a renewable
and um
let me find it bear with me a second
it is
well i'm just reading them and it does
say no outside storage so that's in
there there we go
just sorry scrolling down it takes a
little while on the screen
and i'll find the bullet number
[Music]
nearly there sorry uh
gemma just just i hope i think the third
bullet up from the bottom of the list of
um it's always at the bottom isn't it
renewable to be agreed and the learning
point for officers convenience as well
is number the conditions rather than
using bullets
ev charging points as well yeah energy
and so the third up from the bottom is
energy and renewable integration ski
probably taking an integration scheme to
be agreed and then about
five up from that is ev charging points
how clearly the expectation is that the
wording of that condition would pick up
on the requirements of policy
chairman we yeah
yeah well it's been brought up at the
meeting uh very eloquently so i think
that needs to be
taken into account um counselor
strangers that i thought there were five
or well there were five there is that
sufficient now thank you i think so so
so are we mentioning cs3 in there
because i said i couldn't find it
yeah it's just for helping for everyone
that's reading it consequently yeah yeah
phil yeah yeah
yeah i think i think in terms of the
wording of the condition that we might
expect
the the reason behind that would
certainly be cs3 so it would get
mentioned in the full wording of the
condition
but i absolutely take the point as far
as the committee report it would have
been much more helpful for members to
understand that it was related to cs3 at
this point so
leave that with me i'll take that away
and learning point along with perhaps
numbering the conditions as phil
mentioned to
help make things easier for us yeah i
think that's good for the future thank
you for that
um so um thank you councillor stringer
if you'd like to put hand down and then
counselorfield you you you had a
question and you were trying to help us
earlier
and i know gemma will be looking to see
if she can find some pictures with some
trees
but your point please your question
thank you
right a couple of questions one one
thing it would be quite useful if gemma
could flip to that slide that shows that
the building that's currently going on
on the site sort of gives a bit of
context
but um a couple of questions
the new entrance and the discussion
about it
and sort of understand the left turn and
things i got that put in to
reduce and it has effectively cut the
fatalities at that junction it's column
to zero which is good
um the but the entrance i understood
that there is an application in a moment
to delay the construction of the new
entrance
which was required by the last planning
permission
and there's a comment so so question is
that true and
you know when does that delay stop the
other point is
that you talk about traffic light
control
junctions but there are sort of two
junctions one's addison why one's the
new one
it's totally unclear to me which one of
those two
um is being proposed to be um traffic
light controlled so so that
that's a clear question
um the next one really is about
the height of buildings uh it's easy to
get confused uh
and i wasn't helped by the discussion so
far
are those heights the 50 meter ridge
height
heights above the ordnance datum
or are they heights above the local or
be it drastically altered
land contour because it's important
because there's quite you know this
the hill there is about 32 meters high
um so could we get answers to those two
points
uh yeah if i start with the heights and
we'll work backwards maybe if that's all
right with you um
so if i perhaps see if we can
see that one a bit larger on the screen
let me go hopefully that's a bit larger
so you can see we've got some finished
floor levels
and ridge heights on this plan um
with the um
levels on the left-hand side showing so
it's um
i think the one of them i think it's
this one i can't quite see it
is um rigid
50.5 um
but i don't think i don't think that's
um
height necessarily altogether it relates
to the levels on the site as well
so you were saying that 50.5 above
ordnance datum i.e equal to the
surrounding hills or is that 50 meters
above the 30 meter baseline
it seems gigantic but i just want to be
sure
so if it helps gentlemen i believe from
that section what you see
you have the the finished floor levels
aod and you have the ridge heights aod
on that drawing which i think is
is is um perhaps less disturbing than
something else uh council
well field that's what i imagined but i
just want to make sure
i'm correct okay the next one was the
um we'll we'll take it as i o aod
heights um the next one was the issue
about
the entrance uh which uh
[Music]
keep moving my mouse about which you
can't see
um the the first entrance from the
traffic lights the one that you're
showing there is that the one to be
traffic light controlled or is it the
one at addison why the next
junction along and is that entrance
you're showing
to be constructed or is there an
application in to delay its construction
i need to check on whether we've got an
application
um again if i just come out if i check
it at this point
um yes we do have a planning application
it has only literally just come out of
its site notice consultation period
and so what we'd say here would
obviously be a little bit guarded
and it does look to vary conditions 20
relating of the of the 17 permission
related to the access road details and
the cycle route improvements we do have
a comment
uh from county but i don't think from
what i'm currently seeing on the screen
that i've got a any information
regarding
uh highways uh as a response just
just yet but i'm i'm just looking
through that file so can we come back to
council field on that
if you would i mean clearly the
committee should be looking at
true information not not not uh
imagination
now i must have as well a real question
perhaps to phil
is there have been a quite a few changes
in professional
views on this documentation particularly
highways england's had a load of issues
the county flooding team had issues
natural england had a range of issues a
lot of these seems to have
disappeared a suspicious local person
might argue what pressures are being
applied to achieve those changes
could i be assured that there isn't any
pressure being applied
um just so i understand
what you're asking sorry is that
pressure to change views on the part of
console t's and stakeholders
it is right so for the record
no um as clearly consulted's views are
console t's views
we don't seek to uh
pressurize if you if you want to use
that word no i don't
uh we don't seek to change console t's
views
uh if we think they're wildly wrong or
creating risk we will point that out
but ultimately they'll as long as they
can stand by those views in
in a public inquiry then the view of a
stakeholder is the view of a stakeholder
and the planning authority's role
and officer's role in supporting that is
to give you a recommendation
taking account of that and we may well
weigh it but we don't
we don't attach pressure to people to
change their
their perspectives um so i'm not quite
sure i
can understand that there's always a
perception if you can't see what's going
on it clearly must be suspicious
but um you know our role and the role
expected by
the government in the nppf is that we
will seek to find solutions right
rather than obstacles and we do do that
so
if if we have a comment which uh
we think can be overcome we will ask
people to explore overcoming it if
that's the circumstance there's no
pressure
if they say no that's their view so be
it
thank you sure thank you for that
assurance
you understand as a local councillor i
run into many conspiracy theorists
um and need an answer i fully accept
that and just
just for record as i'm looking at it at
the moment i can see a comment
from the county contributions manager
what what seems to have been uploaded
into our system as a comment from county
highways i can't at the moment track a
county highways comment on the changes
proposed so i'm still struggling maybe
jammer might be able to track that down
better than i am i'm still working on
that one counsellor
did i get an answer on which of the
junctions is traffic light controlled
you didn't so gemma can you help us on
that one please
i'm just looking
because i don't think the highways
comment says anything um
specifically about that um
can we come back to that councillor
field and let gemma look that one up for
you
because these are questions that um you
know we can
yeah i would be happy i feel that the
committee needs to know the rights
and um you know not to particularly
prejudice things but you understand uh
addison why is very close to the snow
isis roundabout proposal so one wants to
make sure that we
understand truly what is wrong
absolutely yeah i absolutely agree good
you know if we can just leave it to come
back to the thank you
okay yeah thank you councillor field um
so um we don't have any representatives
from the parish council objectual
supporter
but we have the applicant to speak he
might be able to help us on some of
those questions so
do we have the applicant to speak
nick davey is it
uh yes i am here if you can hear me um
if you want to put your video on there
you are yes please we can hear you thank
you very much i think my
video is on hope yeah it is now and we
have three minutes and
um mr carmichael will give you a a time
on that
please so if you'd like to start thank
you
thank you thank you very much members um
i i heard some of the debate
uh some of the um uh i did drop out a
couple of times so i'll try and answer
some of the queries
or the outstanding queries that i did
here but
uh just to give you some background um
in 2019 the committee did grant consent
uh for the new estate roads the judgment
on
brownfield road and the first of the
warehouse buildings on what will
eventually be
the 15.5 hectare port one uh logistics
park
now that building is due to complete
next month
it's an 8 million pound investment you
should create 150 jobs
and the tenant will be in there from
next month and should be operational by
christmas
uh on the back of that development and
the precise excellent transport links
my client is getting a lot of interest
in the site
and this application is there to try and
meet that need
and it primarily seeks to regularize the
site boundaries
so that we can create more regular plot
sizes and shapes
that are better suited to the potential
needs
and incorporate some four-point hectares
of land into the scheme
that already has permission to be
developed as an industrial greenhouse
accordingly um we're only actually
seeking permission
for further 3.2 hectares of land to be
developed as part of the
or which doesn't already have permission
for employment related development
um one of the slides showed the
additional land
mainly in the southwest corner when you
look at the site plan
most of that land is just going to be
replacement planting ecology
and for drainage ponds
the application as we said follows the
principles established by the current
approval
in terms of the access the layout
building heights
and landscape treatment there has been
some discussion about building heights i
can confirm that the heights shown on
those drawings
are all aod so none of the buildings are
more than 20 meters high
the ridge heights will be 50 up to 50
meters
41 on the lower buildings and there are
all below the tree heights
the trees on the western boundary and
coming to those trees
they were planted by lord blakenham
primarily to screen
his house from the the land
so from the industrial development
that's already there at great blakenum
and the uh
incinerator plant um
we are taking out some trees but we're
putting in far more replacement trees
and you can see that from the landscape
drawings than we're taking out
but do some do have to come out in order
to get a good layout and all the
important trees are protected as to
consultees yes there were some
objections probably on ecology highways
and um landscape first time around but
we've worked hard with your
consultees and we've provided a lot of
additional information
what this application's been in and
we've
hopefully got to the point where we've
satisfied them and they are happy for
the scheme to go ahead subject to
conditions
you need to be thinking of finishing
thank you right um
so just coming through we're also
working with your
highway uh team to try and coordinate
the offsite highway improvements so that
they tie in with snoasus
uh the traffic signal that will be so
the junction will be traffic signalized
is the new one onto brantford road the
full movement one from the estate
it doesn't need to be traffic signal
signalized for the current scheme but it
will be for the entire scheme
thank you you're now well over your
three minutes okay if you have any
questions i'll be pleased to try and
field them
thank you very much indeed so members do
you have questions i think mr davey was
trying to answer some of the questions
for us um
so first of all councillor stringer and
i will come back to
councillor field if his questions
haven't been satisfied
councillor stringer thank you thank you
mr davey
uh just uh sort of asking about the
boundary where it says blue barn lane
is that am i right in thinking that is
where there's sort of almost a cliff the
other side of that
yeah i mean that's the north that's
between ourselves and the snow asis
development
yeah and that has been taken into
account i mean it's not within our
scheme so we won't don't directly
impact on it but indirect impacts have
been taken account in the ecology
and the geology and the archaeology
reports and the
relevant consultants place services are
happy with what we put forward
okay it's just that there was half of
that border is is
tree-lined and the the other bit looks
like developments going
right up to that that lane uh and that
would be a concern to me knowing
the topography of that cliff and and the
ecology that lives there
we're not extending any further north
than the current permissions
so we're not we're not coming any closer
to the lane than the current permissions
thank you for that the answer is that
you're not coming any further north
councillor do you have another question
that's it thank you chair
thank you councillor stringer um any
other members on the committee have
any questions for mr davey
councillor war boys if you'd like to ask
your question please
council of war boys would you like to
ask your question
we can't see or hear you just at the
moment
sorry i was talking to myself here um
yes uh mr david uh could you just sort
of confirm you
the um developer with regards to energy
use sir
and um actually
possible generation of energy as well
yes is this the policy
cs3 question yes yeah
yeah um we have a full sustainability
sustainability and energy statement
submitted with the application it's one
of
the
submitted documents which does commit us
to fully complying with
policy uh cs3
we've done that with the existing
development uh the buildings that will
open
next month there's and we expect a
similar condition
um on the previous consent there was a
condition
which provides that the development
shall proceed in accordance with the
approved drawings
and all the submitted details which
would include the energy statement
and i'd expect the similarly worded
condition on this application
but um there are a lot of cells going on
the roof of that that building that's
going up now
i can imagine thank you thank you thank
you councillor warboys
um if you can put your hands down now
please and um
counselor field then over to you for
your question please
okay thank you good to hear about
photovoltaic cells much better than on
agricultural land um the question's a
simple one it's really about that
entrance
is it to be implemented in the
the current approved scheme or is it
being delivered
what we've actually we it's quite
complicated
i don't want debate it's either yes or
no for councillor field
the the we put an
application at the request of the county
council they've asked us to delay the
implementation of the new junction
so that they can dovetail the
improvements with those coming forward
from snoasus
so they've asked us to delay it for 18
months okay
thank you
good thank you and i believe uh phillip
isbell was just going to
thank you come in with a comment thank
you just just so that members have
a little bit more clarity over this i've
now tracked down a highways comment on
on this application so it's basically an
application under section 73
varying condition 20 of the 17
permission which was
road access details and condition 26
which was off routes
off-road cycle route improvements so
it's basically a completely fresh
application for planning permission as i
say
it's still under consideration so what i
say is measured by
officers keeping an open mind uh got
comment back from
county highways on the 1st of october
that's available online
the county do say they don't object the
proposal
however there are a number of comments
in their response
which i won't trouble committee by
reading out suffice to say this does
appear to me that this sounds like a
matter which committee would be
interested in to
give scrutiny for because the comment
coming from highway is certainly
is not without qualification but
literally as read
they do not appear to object to the
proposal but it looks as though they
need some more information but it
sounds to me as though this is a matter
that certainly
would logically in order to give
committee and
the public comfort probably be something
that we'd report to
uh committee in due course chairman
so i mean if members want to review that
in due course
for themselves they can do i don't think
it alters this
the the revisions to the access
arrangements for the sake of the record
are not varied at the moment
so they have no planning permission and
the currently agreed access road
arrangements
are still standing as uh required under
the 17 permission
thank you chairman thank you that's
helpful
right now then what we haven't done is
asked
the committee if they have some
questions for councillor field
so do members of the community have
questions for councillor phil
please
[Music]
no right sorry about that john
i think you've covered everything i
think that's probably the issue i
haven't thought
about yet i've only asked questions oh
haven't you oh well then please please
give us your
your um your input then i think that's
the most important thing
thank you i will continue
see how well i read uh
i i think in the past both i and the
community
have supported this development it's an
employment site of some value
it's close to the county town and to the
a14
so and clearly we want to live in a
prosperous area with good employment
so we have supported these sites
however the sheer volume of development
in gipping valley raises questions
and and the need for effective action to
minimize
effects or eliminate developments and
can no longer be
accommodated parish councils have made a
number of points clearly
and i will add to some of those i hope
uh on highways particularly it's always
a major consideration
apparently congestion is not identified
by modelling who was
as a result of these proposals however
such issues were identified by highways
england
and appear to have been with withdrawn
this is despite the acceptance of
applications that will increase traffic
substantially particularly snow asis
blaken and mill
blake and field sites are not yet
complete and several smaller sites in
the area
the approach to the clayton interchange
is congested now
in exactly the way highways england
have questioned and it's difficult to
see why that's not a limiting factor
this is a real problem and we need to
accept the road to the finite capacity
if we want synosis perhaps something
must go
extension to the this side that we have
supported in the past
is perhaps the necessary saturation
particularly as the viability of the
site will be affected by any traffic
congestion in its a14 access
and that is something i've witnessed on
the way home regularly it's not just
make believe
flooding again i think is really
significant
and perceptive officers concerns appear
to have vanished
they will be dealt with at the river
reserve matters
stage and perhaps that's a little late
the mention of discharges being above
ground level which
obviously might be interesting but
difficult to achieve
may be addressed but the levels of the
chalk that hold water which supplies
ipswich will not have altered
these are not issues that should be
identified then dismissed
you and we need clear evidence they've
been resolved
i'm not satisfied the documents contain
that evidence
the environmental impact is the next
point
there's a major bat colony involving
some thousands of animals
some of them very rare species at the
little blaken and pit which is less than
a kilometer away
and those rare species range over a
considerable distance in search of
food and were a major concern for the
snoasus application
apparently not at risk from the
cumulative impact of that
and this site natural england were very
concerned appointed that this is a
material consideration
it appears to vanish it's similar for
the great nested
great crested new colony whose needs can
apparently be accommodated with ease
again major concern for other
applications and
various measures mitigation measures
seem to be extremely difficult to
achieve they're certainly not
progressing forward in my
view on the visual immunity issue
thank you to the agent for the clarity
about the building
heights but they're still pretty massive
buildings
um they're comparable to the
fw plant uh certainly in an area
if if not perhaps in height it's and
it's difficult to see
well it i would say it's difficult to
see why certainly perhaps stack of
cranes do need 20 meter
building heights my concern is that they
will dominate the crisis properties at
little black and uncommon
which were faced by an 11 meter high
greenhouse and now have a
20 something meter high warehouses
assuming the 50 meters is from
quite a high ground level um
and that's true of all the buildings
they're high buildings uh
20 20 odd meters is quite a height but
they sit on top of a 32 meter hill
they will be visible over a wide area
above the
50 to 55 meter height of the surrounding
hills
i haven't seen a visibility analysis
significant doubts of the condition
concerning building heights aimed at the
reserve matters application is strong
enough so that's doesn't seem to be
comprehensive it's my
views which sort of lead me to the
thought that although i like the
employment aspects and i think as much
as
this is an appropriate site and i would
not i have supported the existing
development and would have supported
this i am concerned that there are a
whole range of issues that have not been
addressed satisfactorily
to my mind that need to be addressed for
the committee to be clear
on the decision it's making thank you
thank you john um sorry it was because
you'd sort of had quite a few questions
earlier i sort of lost it that you
haven't
given us your full views of it and now
you have so thank you very much
so do members have questions for the
ward member please
i don't seem to be having any here um i
would just make a comment that um
particularly on your um comments
regarding ecology and bats
um i have did bring it up right at the
beginning to make sure that there is
some condition
uh stronger than just the wording in the
um
in the report so i take on board what
you're saying there thank you very much
so we now move open over
um to debate and we can start off with
councillor castin please
thank you very much madam chairman um
this has been a difficult one from the
start
for me because i'm very pro
let's get let's get the infrastructure
let's get the jobs
let's get money into the economy and um
that's how i feel and generally that
this is a really good site
it's um it's exactly the type of
development
i want to see in this area but um
it looks to me like that first
development kind of picked the
low-hanging fruit in what would um
what would do the least impact
and now we're looking at the slightly
more complicated um
issues where the big issue for me
with this is that the um
how it goes into the trees the um
there's a
really there's a really strong good belt
over they look like fir trees um
and they're established they're um then
you know we're near we're near the um
back colony i'm not sure if
enough's been done to um
to mitigate the um the issues with
having it so close to this um
blakenum pits the um the gipping
river is a really important corridor
through there as well
and it's slowly it's slowly losing
this cover and this harborage for
wildlife
um which is really important but um
the um for me
um it does impact the environment
greatly this application
i think in this debate what i want to
hear from
councillors is that the
the the growth
and the jobs and the um boost to the
economy that this gives
is doing them is offsets that harm of
removing these trees and the um
how that it is particularly the um
the warehouse at the top of the line um
that cuts in um it's hard to
hard to explain but we've got four in a
row but there's the one um
sort of great blake in him side sort of
cuts deeply into the um
into that tree belt and
i'm not too happy about it it's what
i'll say at the moment
i'll um i want to listen to this debate
and i think it's really important that
we um
we we look at this because um it
it does it does strike me as it does do
a great deal of damage
yeah thank you for that councillor
caston
um just before i move on um councillor
humphreys was your hand up for a
question because i'm just going to pop
through a to z for the moment
no sorry my fault right okay
um so we'll come to councillor gould
thank you
thank you very much uh madam chair um
the yes the this is a balance for me
between
the benefits of the economic
employment benefits the site in
most respects seems very appropriate and
and already substantially developed
and i started thinking that this was an
easier issue than um
and i view it to be and it is the
balance between those economic benefits
and the
impact on the ecology
plus the uh the con
concerns that i have around the highways
issues and i i kind of doubts were
increased slightly with the chief
planning officer's invitation to
members to kind of scrutinize uh this
issue or take take views on it so i'm
like cancer customer i'd be interested
to hear the views of others
but um i feel less certain on this than
i
i did uh say uh an hour or half an hour
ago
but i hear what others say thank you
yes councillor cool thank you very much
for that um
councillor humphreys please
i'm chair thank you um isn't it great
news that in this
time of national maths and employment
that somebody's got the confidence to
actually
develop and bring jobs to mid suffolk i
think should be really thankful for that
but i don't think it should be at any
cost however
this is an ideal area for it it's an
area that's already been developed
it's where we've got mass employment now
but to bring 600 more jobs
i think that is a really important point
that we should not
dismiss this is a suitable location
it's sustainable it's got good links to
the a14 whilst i understand the concern
over the road access
this would be resolved i'm sure at
reserve matters
and again we wait for more information
pacific county council
in terms of flooding page 197
para 8.2 and suffolk county council
have now no longer have an objection
they had one before
but after more information has come
forward they've withdrawn that
objection so i think the the flooding
issue isn't isn't as major as we might
think
they cut and again on bats page 157 the
applicant
has done many surveys and we haven't got
the access to the information
but it's in the report and it says
there's no evidence of bats or uses of
bats
however i don't think we should
disregard it and i think because it is
close to that back colony
that we put some protection measures in
by condition
anyway the area is already being
developed
with consented development already going
on and the area's been
pretty much cleared but i think it is
important to maintain as much of the
tree belt as possible
and maybe that could be a condition as
well when we talk about the heights of
the buildings
um gemma thank you for the slides they
put in it's it's really good to
visualize the heights
and the surrounding buildings are
already there and projected to be there
but there is a condition already in that
says the heights will you matter
for detailed consideration at the time
of reserve matters
and a reference to 50 meter ridge height
is not part of this outline planning
permission
and that's a proposal and that's an
important point to take away
so that will be reserved matters
overall i think this is the right place
it's got good access to the a14
to the rest of the country and to the
port felix though it's an ideal place
for religious
logistical uh base the amount of jobs
that we're going to bring to this area
600 or thereabouts is it can only be a
good thing
i can't see many reasons why we would
not go along with this
however i'll wait until i've heard from
other councillors but on the face of it
it's the right place it's the right time
it brings the right jobs
thank you thank you for that councillor
humphreys councillor mellon please
yes thank you yeah um yeah like uh other
councillors have been saying there's
clearly a balance to be struck here
between the
economic benefit of of this development
and the other factors which come in
obviously there are going to be a large
number of increased
lorry journeys and we already know that
the a14
is crowded um as the
um the war members has said the visual
impact is going to be substantial from
this
but the area which i have the most
concern about and where i don't feel
i've got enough
information at the moment is about the
ecology
um there's a lot of information in there
about bats
but that's not the only species
or group of species that is going to be
affected by the removal of trees i mean
if it
if we're talking about a mature oak tree
that could have 300
different species of invertebrates and
all sorts of other things
uh you know using it as a habitat not
just bats you know
what about the birds what about the bees
what about other things
um so i don't have enough information
about the trees
what species are there that are going to
be lost what is their height
what is their age i'm very wary i'm sure
other members are too
of uh approving something which could
end up with the removal of
ancient oak trees as we've seen in other
sites um
so i i at the moment i i don't feel
minded to support this thank you chair
sorry i'll meet cathy
sorry i'm clicking the wrong things
council and norris if you would please
thank you
sorry i i hadn't actually asked to speak
at this point
well i'm going through a to z to see if
anybody wants to enter the debate first
you see
oh okay sorry because it gets everybody
the opportunity to have a go and then
they
um like uh councillor mellon um i have
some concerns regarding
ecology and other
protected species that might be on the
site i've also got
um some concern regarding the traffic
movements
out of the site we've heard about the
left turn
going up to the roundabout coming back
the other way
by going around the roundabout and then
coming
down back along branford road which
would take
heavy traffic through spartan i'd just
be interested to know
from the officer um whether there is a
weight limit through
sprouting or any other measures that
could be enforced
so that's all thank you yes that that
that's a
a useful comment there and um if we can
ask
i'll carry on members
saying their part in the debate we'll
ask gemma if there is a weight limit
up there so that's a very useful
question thank you
so we now come on to council of war boys
please
all right thank you chair um
yes uh i think
well when i first looked through this i
i was confessed i
greeted do the same enthusiasm as
councillors
it is good to have investment and
attracting jobs and it
is on first sight a really appropriate
place however i think i find very
influenced by the measured uh
comments by council the ward member
councillor field
um there there are concerns
uh the on whether or not i'm really
convinced by what's being said about
them
i think the impact on road structure
from um
and the junction at claydon i i'm not
convinced that's been
um answered or scrutinized properly i i
i'm not clear about in particular the
the delay in um
in developing the junction i i can't see
the purpose for that especially as
during the building work there's going
to be increased lorry movements anyway
so i should have thought the junction
should surely come before the
development
um similarly impact on biodiversity
water source and drainage
and the visual impact i think has gone
through but the
the notion of the 20 meters building on
top of the 30 meter hill
is something that really needs to be
considered
um councillor casting brought attention
to the um
the layout of the buildings it's slight
six in
particular and it refers to building
eight
um which really does reduce the
the wildlife corridor we we could see a
removal
of that corridor but being replaced by
tree planting in the southwest corner
but it's it's reduced to a minimum
up in that northwest corner by the size
of
building eight and seven um
so i think that the layout could be
considered a little bit more sensitively
with to
maintain that wildlife corridor um
thank you thank you for that council of
war boys
uh councillor stringer thank you
yeah i i think i'll concur with with
most of what the other councillors have
said
uh this at first glance looks like a
what you call a shoe-in
you know already a majority of this is
already approved
but then you then get into the details
and i have to say it's that
top left corner on the plan uh
uh at 3.1 uh the that really gives me
big concerns
uh i know the area relatively well i was
on the original sis planning committee
so the topography of here i'm sort of
familiar with
and how biodiverse this area really is
it is truly uh remarkable
what unique species we have in this area
and and and it really seems although
the applicant is doing what they've been
charged to do which is
you know bring about economic uh
activity and return and investment
but i really think this could have been
the design of this or the the layout of
this
precludes a truly sustainable
development in terms of that
biodiversity
it almost looks like it it sort of
imposes its will rather than works with
and and i think to me how it's sketched
out at the moment
it looks like a missed opportunity
thank you for that councillor stringer
um well listening to you all
um uh i'm in agreement with all of you
um you know we we've looked at this and
it seems an absolutely excellent
um location for such
jobs um and all the rest of it but i
think there are too many ponderables
here at the moment that we haven't
really
got satisfied and i think councillor
field drew attention to it along with
councillor castin
um of the biodiversity i mean that was
something i was worried about myself in
the beginning
and i wonder really whether we ought to
link this with the section 73 highways
proposal
and defer this for the moment to see
everything as one
rather than doing things piecemeal
and uh i wonder if i can ask uh philip
to comment on
that suggestion if i put that forward as
a proposal
uh thank you chairman um i think
uh in in the circumstances bearing in
mind i would probably expect to report
that section 73 application to committee
um uh if that's what members wish to do
that
uh has some wisdom behind it i would
perhaps welcome
if we're going to take the application
away and review those matters together
and then bring them back to committee it
would be useful to have some
uh guidance as to what members wishes
might be in relation to this layout
question
uh looking at i think these are
identified as buildings
seven and eight which certainly infringe
into one of the planting belts whether
there are
particular focuses that members or
committee might wish us to
uh take away and look at with the
applicant now would be the time to do
that
if that's what members uh wish for um so
clearly in your hands chairman uh quite
a lot of logic to linking the highways
uh question with this given what i've
seen on the application
uh as it presently stands for that um
and and to be able to come back and pull
the threads together will be useful if
there's a bit more instruction as to
what
members would wish us to to look at
yes well from the chair um i've sort of
made the proposal but if anybody wants
to make the proposal from
i say i've made the proposal i've made
the suggestion if somebody wants to
um put flesh on that from the floor
we would want more presumably with
highways biodiversity and flooding but
councillor casten
uh yes if you would like to um make an
offer there please
well it's not so much to um make an
offer it's just to um
say to the um say the counsellors i
think we've got to
decide here whether this needs tweaking
or whether fundamentally where those
warehouses are
is a problem on this application because
um
i think um if we if
the right planting and maybe a
um a reduction to um certain areas
i think this could become something
quite acceptable to me but i think
i think the tweak here and a twig then
maybe won't quite cut it
on this one what i was thinking
not tweaking exactly but um having more
information
um and working with these section 73
is where i'm thinking i need a proposal
to for the officers to take that away to
look at it
um but that i i see what you're saying
i'll go around the other councillors to
see how they want to
perhaps take it forward um councillor
stringer you've got your hand up thank
you council casting
how did you finish with your comments i
was just going to say yeah with that
course of action i do feel that i don't
know enough about i know that
clayton roundabout
traffic level is quite high from being
the ward councillor there and
in the in my last ward um
it's i don't feel like we have got
enough information
yeah from this highway side but i'll let
you um
speak to councillor stringer thank you
councillor casten
councillor stringer first and then
councillor humphreys
thank you i think actually the the
committee has expressed its
uh its support and its reservations
quite well on this one
and i would certainly uh second any or
propose if you need to
to defer this application just to have
one last look at this
uh we have to bear in mind that quite a
lot of this development is already
approved in some way shape or form but i
think there's
there's there's been clear reservations
expressed by
by members some members um and i've
looked at the
application itself to make sure if we
were to defer it
it could be amended but and it could
because the actual
square meterage of building is not part
of the actual
uh headline as it were of the
application
so the sheds technically they've
obviously gone through
an assessment economically whether
they're economically viable et cetera
and people want them
but that there's certainly i think there
is some considerable wiggle room here to
actually look at this
in a bit more of a sensitive manner
thank you for that council stringer
councillor humphreys
ma'am chair yeah thank you i agree with
councillor stringer the um
obviously under not it's not reserved
matters biodiversity
improvements that's one of them wasn't
it and and then the general layout
protection of the trees that's the other
information we want
not just the the highways side of it so
yeah i'll do a second
uh move towards deferral so we can get
that information
so um am i taking it that councillor
stringer you are
happy to propose it with with those
issues i think
phillip is bill just wants to be clear
on what we're asking them to go away
with
but we do need to link it to that other
one which i think would be sensible
um the section 73 highways proposal uh
philip if you'd like to just
help us here we i think you know where
we're going thank you chairman
i'm trying to read the tea leaves as we
go um and what i'm understanding is that
i think we're now talking about a
deferral of the application absolutely
in order to uh review and
as need be reflect on the biodiversity
mitigation
measures um because i'm pretty sure that
what we've seen is
the advice we have is that the harm is
is is not
present but mitigation is a different
question that there is certainly an
interest
in the question of layout and uh product
protection of trees to be uh and any
amendments associated with that to be
considered
and obviously to report back together
with uh the related
section 73 application so the highways
issues can be considered as one and
that's
kind of where i got the deferral but if
if that if i've got that right or got
that wrong i'd welcome
advice chairman councillor stringer that
seems to be where
i was thinking is that where you're
thinking yeah absolutely i think there's
that
we get the reports of saying there would
be no harm
but but wildlife uses corridors and you
can see the existing corridors
and you know where the triple s i is and
and there's a there's a there's
a considerable wiggle room there to
keep as much as possible of those
connectivity wildlife routes
that are at the moment now down to one
tree thick
and and of course from councillor
humphreys when you mentioned it earlier
you know it really is an exciting
prospect that somebody is developing
this with all those jobs
so it's a fine balance so councillor
humphreys are you happy with the
uh the the the comments uh to second the
proposal for deferral yes um and uh and
i agree with you
not it's an ideal place for it we just
need to make sure it's right
so i'm supportive of the scheme but we
do want that extra detail as you just
explained
and councillor field i think you just
wanted to come in on that for us
yes i'm not sure i'm allowed to speak at
this time not really but
just just to slightly bend the rules i
totally agree with the bits about
employment and things i i just want to
say but the the real
i i would like to see an element of
getting highways to look at the clayden
junction again because i think it it's
existing that can
it's congested about halfway back to you
don't go on about it
you've got a bit of leeway here john
sorry i'd like to see something on there
just to make sure because it impacts on
on site viability and things so if we
could
had that i'd be grateful if you can't
it's clearly your dis
yeah well i think i think we'll leave it
as it is i think um the
planners will no doubt incorporate all
of that i think we've made it quite
clear
so um philip are you happy with um our
proposal for deferral on the basis that
we've just debated
uh i i think so chairman just so uh
yes uh and uh and it would come back to
this committee with the other
application
so that we would effectively report the
the current live section 73 application
and this together to you together with
any amendments
an update on the biodiversity mitigation
and any changes to the layout which
uh address any issues concerning the uh
tree protection
aspects that members have talked about
here
and clearly as we've only just closed
the consultation period on that section
73
application case officer will need a
little time to write the report but
there's a window of opportunity there to
bring both back together in one go
thank you very much indeed so on that
basis can i now ask robert to go for the
vote on the proposed
deferral
thank you chair so if i could please ask
members
to respond with for against or abstain
so councillor james carsten poor
counselor peter gould four
councillor cathy guthrie full
that's the barry humphries
council andrew mellon four
councillor mike norris four
that's the red and wool boys four and
council andrew stringer
four thank you chair that is unanimous
well thank you very much indeed
everybody um i think we can have
um a 10 minute break now is that alright
if we just have 10 minutes
sounds good yeah just keep keep the
screen
my
thank you chair i'll now take a roll
call to check that all members
are present thank you so much councillor
james carsten
president
boys
cancelable boys
you've pitted me on mute counsellor i'll
come back to you counselor boys and
counselor stringer
so let's just
wait two minutes i will message
counselor ball boys
okay
i've messaged council warboys chair just
asking to confirm
mm-hmm
could be having difficulty with the
internet it's quite windy out there i'm
wondering if there's an issue there
can you tell
us now yes i'm back
oh good brilliant thank you council
we're all here slow kettle i'm afraid
right are we live
thank you very much indeed and we now
move on to the third
and final case for today dc
20 03026 chris nicholson's site
land adjacent to weatherton road
elmswell
so i'll now invite alex scott to
introduce the case for us please thank
you very much
thank you chairman and i will try and
present my screen
there we are i hope you can all see that
and i will move to the slideshow
presentation
okay um well good morning
uh chairman and members um this
is application reference dc oblique 20
oblique 03026 it is an application made
under
section 73 of the town and country
planning act
for the variation of a condition
and specifically condition one that is
approved plans and documents of
previous approval reference dc oblique
18
oblique 01679
which granted reserve matters for the
erection of
240 new dwellings
including 84 affordable homes to the
north
and south of weatherdon road to the
southeast
side of elmswell
the original application was considered
and
granted by committee on the 4th of
october
2018. the current
application seeks permission for the
alteration
for alterations to the scale and
appearance of 39 of the 240 dwellings
originally approved that
equates to um from my calculation 16.25
percent so
16 and a quarter percent of the total um
the affordable dwellings are not
um proposed to be affected and
the proposal relates only to the private
market dwellings
previously approved
and in overall summary
the proposal will introduce 10
new uh housing designs and these have
not
been previously considered by uh by
committee they are new designs
for the purposes of this application and
there will be
um some uh designs as previously
approved
which will be lost and i'll run with
those uh through you
um run run those past you
know so i'm trying to get my my words
out excuse me i'll run through those in
in a while as i go through the
presentation
um and the proposal would result
in the the loss of two
two-bedroom dwellings uh just to make
you aware of that um
however there were across the wider site
60
um two-bedroom dwellings approved so
we're going from 60 in total to uh
to 58. and in the place of the um
the two-bedroom dwellings there will be
one three-bedroom dwelling
and one four-bedroom dwelling additional
proposed um in effect by where this
application
um so we will move on to the
presentation itself and the first slide
is the location of elmswell uh within
the district
for the avoidance of doubts
this is a wider aerial view of the area
showing uh the settlement boundaries and
the site
edged in red here for you and
for the avoidance of that we have
elmsweil here will pit
here whether done here paulie here and
holly green
there on the plan for you um
this slide is a superimposed um
area of the uh the site we're looking at
an aerial view um please bear in mind
this is an older
picture and works have actually
commenced on site
as i will show you in the later
photographs i have as part of
this presentation and we have a 3d image
of
the the area and uh village
again an older photograph
please bear that in mind we have the
um the constraints uh plan for you um
outside the village settlement boundary
as defined in the
uh in the plan however the principle has
already been established
and for the purposes of today i think
the the main constraint
is the public footpath which runs along
the south
and uh east boundaries of the uh
southern parcel of the uh of the site
this is the redline site location
plan as already approved
as part of the original planning
permission and this is
carried forward as part of this section
73
application for revised reserve matters
and this is the layout as already
approved and the
layout as proposed and the white areas
highlight the the areas of concern for
this application so in the southern
parcel
only and the
dwelling's proposed to be altered
this is a close-up of the layout as
approved
and i
i have um added to these plans um
[Music]
just just for the importance of doubt um
which the areas where we're dealing with
um so the areas uh we're interested in
outlined in red
and um the the yellow dots
um indicate the dwelling's proposed to
be um
altered as part of this current
application and
um just for your information um as
requested by
um the chair and vice chair at briefing
i have
uh indicated the two-bedroom dwellings
proposed to be lost in in green for you
there so i
hope that's helpful and then a um
a zoomed in view of the
the layout as proposed
these are the uh dwellings previously
approved the designs previously
approved which are proposed to be lost
as part of this current
uh application and
i've indicated the number of each design
underneath
each dwelling for you
and these are the proposed uh new
dwellings
um as i said these uh these are new
designs for the purposes of this
application and these haven't been
previously considered by um by committee
and again the number
of each uh design uh underneath
uh for reference there
now in terms of um comparison
um i've set the
what has been approved in terms of the
four bedroom dwellings above the line
here um
so you can directly compare this to the
four bedroom dwellings which
are um showing below the uh
below the line there and um again as
requested by the chair and vice chair
um i've added the average
internal floor space square meters
for you there above and
what is now proposed so that is the
average
for the four bedrooms moving on to the
two and three bedrooms
um again above the line what was
previously
considered and granted and what is now
proposed in terms of three bedroom
dwellings
and for the three bedroom dwellings only
we have the average
floor areas and again what is now
proposed
below for you
onto some street scene elevations this
was
what was previously considered and
approved
and the street scene elevation of most
relevance
is uh the middle one uh street scene b
for the purpose of this
application and that is a view from
the from the east looking in
as you're approaching uh from from
weatherden direction
and this is the street scenes as uh as
currently
proposed and uh the next slide
i have a comparison of um
street scene b uh above is what
was previously granted below is now what
is
currently proposed and again
as uh requested by the chair and vice
chair
i've added the uh the distance uh
between
uh each uh each building for you um
this is what was uh approved this is
what it's proposed so i hope that's
helpful in terms of comparison as well
onto some photographs um this
was taken a while ago
in 2018 um and this
is taken from the footpath to the the
rear of the site
towards weatherton road and then looking
around to the uh to the right to the
east of that previous photograph
out of the village towards weatherton
direction
and then further round the footpath back
towards
weatherdon road here so we have the
southern parcel here and across
um in the fields is the it's a northern
path
this is uh as you come out uh onto
weathern road from the public footpath
this is looking
towards weatherden then back towards
elmswell
and um this is the uh the area of the
uh the southern parcel
and then uh walking up uh the road
towards the village again further
this is a view of the northern parcel
and then towards the um the affected
neighbor to that side
this is a recent photograph um
[Music]
as i mentioned at the top the um the
development is
underway and this uh this hoarding has
been uh erected
around the southern parcel this is
looking out of the village towards uh
weatherdon direction and
the opposite view looking back towards
uh the village and as you can see some
of the uh the dwellings have been
have been commenced on the southern
parcel
and um this is the uh the northern
parcel
and as you can see uh a lot of the
dwellings uh
uh completed there as well
and that completes the presentation and
um also recommendation as set out in the
papers for you thank you chairman thank
you very much for that alex and thank
you for those additional pieces of
information i think that gives us
a good grounding so i'd leave one of
those up for the time being
and do we have any questions
for the officer please
um i will go to the ward member that the
ward member last if you don't mind
councillor mansell
so councillor humphreys followed by
councillor custom
thank you madam chair thank you um yeah
good presentation
also it makes sense the question i got
is
on this slide actually so where you got
13.7 meters
and below it 11.8 meters just left the
center of the screen
can you confirm that's a road within the
estate
uh yes i can confirm that's a road in
this within the estate but the road
width will not be
um be altered as part of this current
application just to confirm that
does that include the pavement not not
getting any smaller
um no the the changes are within the um
the cartilages the plots
themselves so the patent size won't be
changing that's not proposed
thank you and thank you and now
councillor gaston please
thank you very much madam chair um just
to make sure my maths are
all right on this are we um
is the have we approved 39 houses and um
do does this propose putting 50 houses
where 39 were
before just so unclear
um sorry sorry the um
we're not approving any any more um
dwellings the the number will
will stay the same if that's just it's
just a design and bedroom
number in with regards some of them but
they'll change
all right thank you yeah that's that's
why i asked the questions
yes yeah there aren't any additional
ideas proposed yeah yeah
thank you thank you and councillor
boysen can you take your hands down
if you've already spoken thank you
council of war boys
yes i think it's just a slight
previously it's about the
the proposed changes in dimensions of
the houses
uh that just affects the
the replacement houses i think the three
four
bedroom houses go down from was it 120
no it's all the houses go down in size
all the houses go down in size
houses within this proposal so um
the ones that he had that uh alex
highlighted sorry i've interrupted alex
you you explain it
um yes you show the highlights picture
alex
yes he hasn't yeah the highlights
picture here there are the um
four dwellings the layout oh i'm sorry
yes
i'll go back to the uh okay yes so this
is this is the
layout as was approved so here are the
um
the dwellings um affected as previously
um
approved and they are proposed to be
replaced with um
the designs um as shown in the remainder
of the presentation
exactly they're all a lot smaller than
what was shown originally
um the floor areas are slightly smaller
as i've um
set out there yes yes yes
sorry to interrupt yeah that's sorry i
had the same questions myself at
briefing so
yeah and just just uh to get carol i
don't know if you could give me the
information how does this relate to sort
of minimum size
sizes that are recommended for say a
four-bedroom
house um well in terms of
um nationally described space standards
um
i mean we do we don't have a policy
presently so
in terms of um you know insisting on
this from a
from a planning perspective i think it
would be very difficult particularly for
the the market dwellings and we are only
looking at uh
market dwellings here um the
um the space standards were previously
uh considered by strategic housing
um from the the host application for the
affordable dwellings and that was
considered
acceptable but um
yes i mean we don't have a policy which
is the difficulty really
i would uh summarize really okay
thank you thank you for your question
councillor warboys
um and now councillor mansell please
uh thank you chair um i've been playing
a sort of spot the difference
on on the slides that we got in our
papers
um and i would just like to query uh i
think it's plot number 103
which on our papers in slide 11
is not highlighted in white as one of
the ones that's changing
but it looks very different to the plot
103
on my paper version of slide 10 so i'd
just like to query
is that a change or or what has happened
because the house on the approved layout
doesn't look like what we've got on the
proposed layout but it's not
highlighted as a change if that makes
sense
um sorry plot plot 103.
103 is is the lower
line you've outlined in red yes uh the
bottom
left-hand side of it there's a plot
there which looks like it sort of faces
west
but on on ah that's different
oh that's not the same as the one i've
got in my papers
that's bizarre um
on my paper version of slide 11 that
house
is facing south
oh sorry that's the approved layout
sorry the approved layout is based west
on the proposed layout it looks like
it's facing south
it's sort of rotated by 90 degrees okay
oh yes i can yes yes
um
[Music]
yeah well perhaps that's a question for
the the applicant that isn't that isn't
part of the um
proposal i'm aware um
perhaps you'd like to save that one
counselor mansell for the okay thank you
yes yeah we did we definitely need to
question it the applicant is here for me
to question
yes okay thank you thank you i'll i'll
hold that one for you sarah
yeah counselor mansell
right no further questions
um in fact
we don't have a representative from the
parish council objector or supporter
so the applicant can now speak if you
would please
andrew owen you have three minutes and
our officer will
uh tell us when you're near the three
minute thank you
brilliant thank you and good morning
councillors um yes my name is andrew
owen and i'm the planning manager
for chris nicholson responsible for the
delivery of this application
um i have written down quite a few bits
to say but i think the officer's
um report and presentation have covered
the majority of it
just to take you through um the query
from the ward councillor there
we do have a separate um full
application for an additional unit
which is why that plot sits under a
separate application
um but it it's why that has changed
so just to clarify that point that's
subject to a separate
application which is
before the council and in terms of
this application before the coronavirus
pandemic we'd had a lot of customers
come to site and
um looking for smaller three and four
bedroom units
and i think everyone spent a lot of time
in their homes
during the pandemic and have sort of
reviewed their situations
um and thanks to the stamp duty holiday
and help to buy and crest also has its
own shared ownership home reach
product at the moment we've looked to
provide
a better mix of properties reflective of
the market demand
so it enables people who possibly can
have afforded a three bed before to
stretch to an entry level three bed
that provides them some flexible space
for home working and things which are
obviously more important at the moment
and so ultimately that's that's the
drive behind
behind the changes before you today the
material pallets and
all of the high quality design has all
been retained
and we've got about 80 of the 240 homes
occupied at the moment
so the site's coming along well
extensive open space with suds and
wildflower meadows we've got bat and
bird boxes in
hedgehog friendly fencing to properties
all of those
main principles of the scheme are
retained as well so
um on parking again the provisions
compliant with highways policy and
so there are no objections from any
statutory council tease and
obviously hope that you vote to approve
the application
in accordance with the officer's
recommendation
thank you for that um i will come to the
members uh i do have a question
a couple of questions myself so it's
just cost that you're reducing the size
of the properties
it's yeah it's it's to provide a product
mix that enables people to
um
yeah and my other question is um
oh i've almost forgotten it cost and
size oh yes um do these properties allow
for a proper double bed
side tables and perhaps a wardrobe um
because often we go and we see them and
they've got three quarter beds and you
can't get
a cat in there yeah just to confirm so
they all they are actually all
national space standards compliant units
so
yes um okay thank you
councillor stringer sorry i might have
jumped your question i'm not at all not
at all
uh just could i just ask a question do
we have
any romsey keswicks red graves
eavesdrops dawkins wink fields
cheshams lansings all marlboroughs
already on
this site no right so these are all new
well new uh yeah they're elsewhere
can i you said you've kept the high
quality design remains in this
so can you show me where you've got some
cor some double hip roofs in here
in terms of in terms of the images
before you
i suppose it's on an individual house
type perspective
the the styles have been have changed as
their smaller properties
they probably haven't got the exact same
features as before
but looking at still using the same
materials in and
um you know just retaining the same
character that we had previously
no that's not correct is it hang on
let's not let's not debate it
councillor stringer we'll debate that
you and i um
andrew has uh andrew owen has answered
the question do you have another
question
counselor stranger uh no thank you chair
thank you councillor stringer councillor
humphreys i'm chair thank you
miss throwing um just go head around it
i think i understand it
they're smaller so that it's a cost
reduction it's cost reduction to you to
build it
but um can you confirm that these houses
are now cheaper than the houses they're
replacing
to buy yes it's driven by the
purchase price essentially so it's
ensuring
that they are cheaper more affordable to
private buyers yes
thank you thank you for that
thank you very much indeed so we now
come
thank you very much mr owen um if you'd
like to remain and listen to the debate
we now come to the ward members um and
so we can ask
uh councillor mansell thank you
uh thank you chair um i i remember
the um debate about the original design
and layout for this development
um uh and i do remember it when
it got deferred it came back because uh
we got it altered
um to make it uh you know we spent i
think a lot of time was spent on the
on getting the layout um acceptable uh
back in 2018.
um so in some respects it's a bit
disappointing
now that we've got this application for
some changes to the housing mix
i'd like to thank mr owen for his
explanation because i
wasn't quite sure of the reason of why
this application was
coming in but i do find it a little bit
disappointing that in our papers we only
seem to have consultation responses
from the original application in 2018
notable there's a lack of a recent
response from the strategic housing team
in the for the original proposal their
comments suggested okay they didn't sort
of recommend
a holding objection or anything but they
did intimate that there was more need
for two and three-bedroomed market
houses rather than
larger houses um so and here we are with
a proposal which seeks to reduce the
number of two-bedroom houses
uh so i couldn't really support it but
having listened
to mr owens explanation as to why it's
being done
um my views are tempered slightly
um and if we're making the houses more
affordable
um then maybe that's a good thing um
i i i was i was a little bit baffled i
think um
but i think having his explanation has
been quite helpful
um so i i i can't really see
any reason to to change this um you know
there are some changes of design in the
house but
um um you know i'm not sure how
significant
a design change that would be it's quite
difficult to visualize
um but thank you for allowing me to make
my comments
thank you councillor mansell and now
councillor geek if you would like to oh
wait
yeah we'll do them i'll do them
afterwards counselor geek if you'd like
to make
comment and then we can ask the members
if they want to ask you both any
questions
thank you chair um could i first say i'm
very grateful for the clarifications
that you and the vice chair suggested to
be added to the report they've been very
helpful in
in understanding the application um
now uh although um there is an
acknowledged need for smaller houses in
elswell and in mid-suffolk generally
um we all know that all the evidence
shows that it's there in your report on
pages 362 to 364.
um there is a substantial need locally
and district-wide for specifically
two-bedroom houses as councillor mansell
has said
so smaller um we we don't in this
country go
purely on a square footage square meters
basis
we tend to think about it in in terms of
the numbers of bedrooms
and there is still a substantial need
for two-bedroom houses so
so as councillor mansell has said
although this is a minor change it's a
minor change away from
uh the two bed houses and that change
should in theory be
resisted but i would agree with
councillor mansell
um if in the point that if the houses
are genuinely more affordable perhaps
that goes some way towards
mitigating the problem thank you
thank you for that councillor geek um
now can we
um just ask alex one quick one how many
two bedroom properties are there on that
side which might just help us i think
that is
yes indeed yes there were 60 approved
and because of the removal of the two
there would
uh in effect be 58 remaining so there
are 58 two-bedroomed houses thank you
so do members have questions for
councillor geek and councillor mansell
and i'm sure they can answer them
councillor stringer have you got your
hand up for questions
sorry chair that's a legacy hand oh a
legacy hand right
um and any any further questions i think
we've we've sorted that one out
thank you very much indeed the ward
members uh so
um we now open to debate and i will come
first to councillor custon please
thank you very much madam chair yes um
i like this the um developers looked
into
what the people want to buy
and they've made a decision to change
the um
the style of those houses as a response
to that
we need um i'm not too worried about
specifications changing within those
houses because
the way i see it people have a um choice
to buy a house with different
specifications
but they can't choose to buy a house
they can't afford so i think this is
going
exactly the direction that i'd quite
like it to
we've got more houses the the houses
will fall into a
group that's affordable to more people
and um
it makes perfect sense to me the year 58
two beds already
on this development it is nice to see
the two beds but i'm
more than happy to have the these houses
generally um 39 houses that are more
affordable
and more available to um people so
that's where i am on it thank you thank
you for that cancer casting counselor
gould
thank you very uh thank you very much
madam chair
uh yeah this is um not a hugely
significant
uh change uh obviously the it's good
that
uh houses are made more more affordable
uh but the economics of this are
probably a benefit
uh to to the builder as well as to the
uh the purchaser uh a personal
point is i i don't like the change
in design for me the uh
the new designs are slightly too
relevant of
uh 1970s 1980s style
houses which personally i don't regard
as a high point
in uh in housing design i
did prefer the altitude science but
there you have it if we're trading that
against
uh the benefit of more affordable houses
than
uh then so be it so i don't i don't
really have a problem with this
thank you thank you councillor gould
councillor humphreys
i'm chair thank you um yeah as councilor
mouse
mansell said this application the
original one was approved
and part of that was on the layout and
the appearance of the actual estate
itself
and we thought it was a good design and
a good layout and that's why we went for
it well partly
i'm glad mr owen explained the reasons
why they've changed or they're proposing
a change
and again this is all market-led as is
the
requirement for two-bedroom or
three-bedroom houses and a gradual move
that people don't want two bedroom
houses anymore they want this space
so it's all market driven and i get that
as well which is the whole reason why
while this is in front of us i guess the
only uh planning
thing that i think this could fall down
on if you were that
way minded is in terms of appearance so
the street scenes slightly changed i
think
we can put it up slide 11 or 13 i think
it is just to illustrate what i'm trying
to say
okay the one below that
and go down one more
one more sorry about this we will get
there
keep going it's the one where you see
the three aspects yeah one more down
that's
it and the one below it so you can see
the center section there
um with the grouping of the smaller
houses where you've got the 2.8 meter
gap
that appearance uh is to some i guess
unacceptable um it's not as good as the
appearance before it so it's it's all in
the eyes of the beholder i suppose
whether you accept that
is it as an acceptable appearance or not
but it does make a definite change to
the street scene
and some people might not like that but
i don't think that's a reason to
to refuse this so i get it i understand
the reasons why it's nice to see that
people are getting what they want for a
change
and that prices of housing is coming
down as well so again
um apart from the appearance i can't see
any real problem with it
thank you for that counselor i'm freeze
counselor malin
yes thank you chair um yes i mean this
seems to be a reasonable adjustment to
the plan
based on you know what houses they're
able to sell um
i do regret the sort of slight loss of
the features that we're getting um
the the new design isn't as good as the
previous
as other councillors have said but um uh
at the moment i'm minded to
uh to be in favor of this thank you
thank you councillor mellon councillor
norris
yes thank you ah yes i understand
council humphrey's comments regarding
the street scene
um it does present the block
of the two blocks of buildings very
close together with only a
very small sort of gap between them but
overall i'm very grateful for the
developer representative explanation
i thought that was very helpful and
i will be supporting this application
thank you
thank you councillor norris councillor
war boys
well yes i think i just got techo i
think there is a some other
a loss in some of the more interesting
design elements
i think the street scene is a little bit
more varied so there's pluses and minus
uh i realize i've been informed got no
policy on it i'm a bit concerned about
the reduction in space i realize it is
to make them more affordable
but we are getting close to sort of
nationally just
minimum nationally described space
standards
and in especially at this time when
people seem to be spending more time
in their homes so that is a concern
and i think we need to be wary of it
thank you council of war boys councillor
stringer
thank you chair uh i'll take a different
tack to many of you
uh we've had a big a load of debate at
the moment in response to a white paper
about how we design things to be
beautiful and how we should
stick to good design codes and not water
down and blend out design
uh this is a perfect example of this uh
also i would like some
i would like assurance because i've done
some calculations myself
the red grave house i believe is below
the national standard
for housing for a three-bedroom house
i've got the table in front of me
it should be 84 square meters to have
four people in it
so you'll have a three bed house you
can't any more than four people living
in it
uh i make it 83.89 square meters
including the walls so uh
if you can live in the middle of a wall
i don't know but i think that dwelling
is actually below the national safety uh
the the standard of size uh these living
rooms that are proposing here are ten
feet two inches wide that's tiny for a
living room
once you put a sofa in it you know and
possibly a television you probably need
to nade it to the wall because
you won't put another cabinet in and
then walk around it so i think that i
have
real problems with this uh we should be
we should accept
that if it was just about approvable
last time
why should we water down design i get
the point people want them more
affordable
as a way to make them more affordable
don't make them semi-detached make them
terrorist
it's quite simple you can then keep the
space and keep the cost down
so frankly i will be refusing this
application and stick by our own
suffolk design code and the national
space standards thank you chair thank
you for that councillor stringer
well i must admit um when i looked at
these um
as acknowledged by councillor geek we
did ask or i did ask
for the sizes of these properties to be
compared
and it comes as no surprise that they
are smaller
the problem we have councillor stringer
and i i support what you say
is that we don't have a policy at the
moment
for whereby we have to have the
standards
um like councillor gould i think it is
going back to a 60s design
i think if i'm misquoting you i
apologize but i think that was mentioned
and i think it is a shame that uh you
know much of the
i hate this word the beautification of
it
um has been watered down a little bit
but i also hear
everybody else's points of view is that
properties need to be affordable and i
have to be mindful
that there are people that do want to
aspire to these properties
um and so um i will be supporting it but
it is with a heavy heart because
i think to come back
when we did have a much better view
for the street scenes but it would be
difficult to say no
so anyway that's where i am at it so if
anybody wants to make a proposal i'll
look in the
hands up situation to see councillor
castin
thank you thank you chair i'm happy to
propose that we approve this
i don't agree with the other councillors
in so much as we want everything to be
of the highest standard that we can
possibly do because
i think with supply and demand you'll
end up with houses go that are more
desirable
they'll go up in money my first house
was
a small house you could barely swing a
cat
in the kitchen a lot of people would
have said oh that would have been a much
better house with a larger kitchen
but a lot of people wouldn't pay more
money for it because it had a small
kitchen
i could afford it it worked well for me
i think um
yes we should build nice houses to the
absolute um the best design we possibly
can but i think we've
also got a really big need
for houses that aren't everyone's cup of
tea
but are affordable to people that um
can't afford to um live on a road where
everything's set out so it looks
incredibly beautiful for them when they
go to work because
we we do need to get these houses right
and there are those houses there's
plenty of those houses in suffolk
we can um we've now got houses that
people can afford
people can go into someone someone like
me could have gone into a three-bedroom
house and i wouldn't have had to change
houses
um when i when i had children so um
i think it does make a lot of sense to
me i don't really see um
the other counselor's points for that
but
to cut a long story short yes i would
like to
propose approval of this application
thank you very much for that councillor
humphreys
mom chair thank you i'd like to second
that proposal and uh
same opinion really they're not the most
beautiful houses in the world but it's
market-led
that's what people want that's what
people have asked for that's what people
are getting
and i would rather see what i've just
seen than rosa terraced houses that are
slightly larger i'm sorry but we've
moved on
and so i do second that proposal
thank you for that councillor humphreys
i have a proposal and a seconder so
anybody wishing to speak
to the motion i saw councillor
stringer's hand there
so if you'd like to speak thank you yeah
i'll be voting against this uh because
there's that chinese curse you're
careful what you asked for you just
might get it
i am absolutely certain people are not
clamoring to have
narrow living spaces to live in they
they want to live in a suitable space
they're not clamoring to have build
buildings
under the national standard i think
that's an absolute disgrace
and i will vote for against that every
time it is poor design
if you can't make it something livable
and attractive
it's not it's not bowing to the market
it's actually designing something
properly
a gp1 says that materials and finishes
should be traditional and compatible
with traditional materials and finishes
and respect architectural styles the the
watered-down design we have here does
not do that
so i'll be voting against this thank you
councillor stringer council of war boys
yeah i think i must second councillor
stringer's remarks
i think uh first of all aesthetically
there's nothing wrong with terrorist
houses
in fact so the most contemporary
buildings are in fact terrorist
buildings um and it adds variety
i think people do deserve uh
proper living spaces and i think it is
quite possible to
do build efficiently and economically
adequate living spaces to people so i'm
concerned about those
um that the quality of that coming down
there is no reasons why people should
have kitchens where you can't swing a
cat
people should have properly designed
kitchens that they can work in
thank you councillor boys anyone else
wishing to speak to the motion
no thank you very much everybody in that
case can i ask robert to go for a roll
call on the
vote please and are we clear the uh
recommendation
uh which is well i've got the paper copy
of three two three
thank you thank you chair
so if i could if members could please
respond with
for against or abstain so council james
carsten
for councilor peter gould
four councillor kathy guthrie
four chancellor barry humphreys
andrew mellon four
councillor mike norris four
casarella warboys against
councillor andrew stringer again
thank you chair i make that by six votes
to two the motion is carried
mr defray i agree six folks to two
carried
thank you thank you very much thank you
very much indeed so that concludes the
meeting
there's no site inspections to report am
i correct on that um
robert that's correct yeah so in that
case
i'll now formally close the meeting um i
should be remaining because i do want a
quick word
um with one or two of the offices but
thank you very much for everybody for
their input thank you
you